sors do
what so uh yeah but it's fun being here
in Paradise isn't it um so the first
bill we have in the docket this morning
before us uh is HB 1288 relative the
establishment of certain due process
rights for students student
organizations and faculty members facing
disciplinary actions by the by state
institutions of Higher Learning and I'd
like to welcome representative cortelli
who's going to uh introduce the bill uh
good morning uh fellow committee members
uh for the record uh state
representative Glenn cordelli
representing tufton buau uh wolfboro and
oapi in the beautiful Lakes Region and
it's um my pleasure to introduce uh
House Bill
1288 um which I think is um very timely
and
important
um um the prior Administration in
Washington uh proposed new title 9 rules
related to due process when uh someone
is accused of sexual harassment or
something like that um those rules um
are now currently the um the law of the
land to provide uh greater um um options
and um due process rights to the uh to
anyone accused of uh of a from a
complaint and the current Administration
in Washington DC has proposed new rules
that roll those um due process rights
back um it is my understanding that
there is a final draft of those rules um
available but um it is still just a
final draft and they have not moved
forward to implement um these new rules
but uh some of the issues that have been
raised in relation to these new rules on
due process for Title 9 UM include um
I'll just mention three or four um a
return to what is known as the single
investigator model which empowers a
college administrator a single
administrator to investigate judge and
sanction any alleged Mis
conduct uh
secondly the um new
regulations um W could deny students
access to evidence against them
providing them only with a description
of relative evidence a summary of
relative evidence and that could be
provided orally rather than any um
written uh testimony transcripts Etc
uh third the rules also allow schools to
deny accused students a live hearing and
the opportunity to question their
accusers which I think is a major major
issue um back in 2018 I'll just point
out that um when the um previous
administration rules were being um
reviewed um there was an effort to uh
postpone
uh those rules put forward by secretary
Devas and the foundation for individual
rights and expression uh noted that
since
2011 and this was in 2018 so seven years
approximately 117 federal courts and as
well as a number of state courts had
raised concerns about the lack of
meaningful procedural Protections in
campus uh uh uh uh reviews of
complaints um I I think that the bill
before
us puts into place for New Hampshire
some very
important uh criteria for due process
procedures uh if you look on page two um
lines four and five the right to receive
notice 7 days prior to a hearing line
seven and eight the right to receive at
least 5 days before a listing of
witnesses who have provided or will
provide evidence uh against the
student down to 11 and 12 the right to
presumption that no violation
occurred innocent until proven guilty I
think we've all heard
about um line 17 the right to confront
and cross-examine
Witnesses in other words the right to a
live hearing of the charges um so that
um the accused can cross examine
Witnesses and on line 19 the right to
provide uh defense and call Witnesses in
support of the person accused I think
all these are
fundamental to our system of justice and
certainly should be in um any uh
hearings uh on um accusations in on
college campuses as well and with these
pending new
rules uh from the current Administration
in Washington I think it is very
important that we set the standard here
in New Hampshire thank you very much
thank you very much are there any
questions of the
representative yes representative luno
sure thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much representative cordelli
for bringing this forward do the um I I
want to go back to where you where you
started with um with the the federal the
changes to the federal uh due process
rules both made by the prior
Administration and being considered now
by the U uh Biden Harris Administration
but do the um do the federal rules apply
to um all schools public and private
that comply with the Higher Education
Act uh I am not positive of that I have
I have read in one um uh article that um
it might not apply across the board and
could apply differently to private and
public um institutions uh especially
geographically based on local federal
court um uh
opinions but I have not confirmed that
okay thanks further questions
representative
B thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh this is in regards
to 7 17 on the first page of the bill 17
and it's Roman numeral 2 faculty member
means a full or part-time member of The
Faculty so would this cover adjunct
instructors um uh I I would think so but
um um representative Lynn will be
testifying shortly and um is the uh
Prime sponsor and could answer that more
accurately than I could thank you thank
you further questions yes representative
Woodcock thank you chairman morning
repres um if I can follow up on um Q's
question on line 17 just a clarification
a few minut where it says uh it does not
include a faculty member who is on
probationary status now is that
probationary status established by uh
amount of time before uh being evaluated
will Pro probationary status because
they've done something in the past and
now they're on probation for a
disciplinary cause yeah again I'll let
representative Flynn um answer that
question okay thank you thank you yes
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question um could you
reference where we look to see where
these pending rules are or what they are
or do you have a copy of that for us um
I don't have a copy of the Draft rules
but I will get that thank
you further question yes represent Luna
thank you again Mr chair um when it um
when you talk about student
organizations why does it apply
to um what what why doesn't it apply to
to just student organizations that are
recognized or approved but also to I
guess I I don't know if you can call it
a student organization but a group of
students who sought recog miss or
approval but failed to receive
such
um I I don't want to put words in
representative Lynn's mouth but I would
think student organization is one that
um has been um recognized by the
institution rather than one who has not
been recognized um that's that's my
opinion follow up on that so so thanks
well the reason I asked you is because I
I think you're the you're well no
represent Lynn is the prime sponsor of
the correct so um so uh yes if if
representative Lynn is is when when he
comes up I'll I'll ask about um about
that because on line 26 it talks about
um a group of students who may have been
denied
recognition thank thank you any F yes
represent whitcock thank you thank you
once again I'll be done with this uh sen
what prompted
this
um I think uh in in my mind um uh it was
prompted by uh information um that we
became aware of about the uh new rules
that were being proposed um and uh uh
concerns expressed about those those
rules um so I think I think it's very
timely um and that the rules have not
been put in place but um are still
pending and in draft form so I I think
we need to uh if you might say get out
ahead of the
game thank you thank
chair there will be a number of other
people coming forth to testify on this
so if it's a question that could be you
know maybe given to one of the others
that are coming up we have people from
the University system as well as you
know further on this bill represent Amon
I'll Rec I you thank you chair lab and
thank you for taking my question it's
actually a followup to representative
woodcock's question
um so I'm just trying to follow the
history and maybe get a little more of
it this bill as I understand it proposes
to secure in New Hampshire statute what
is currently federal statute but may be
changing is that first of all correct
and then I have a i
I think that the uh intention is to yes
put into New Hampshire statute uh I'm
not sure if it exactly matches what is
in current um uh Federal Title 9 UM or I
haven't looked at the current um uh but
I I did not draft this uh uh so um so
this may in fact be for representative
Lynn but just to put it on the
table how does this compare with what
the Fed feral statute
was prior
[Music]
to sorry I'm having to make sure I say
this correctly prior to the Trump
administration because that's the
current one is that correct that that is
correct so then I mean prior to before
that how does it
compare um some of the um uh language in
the proposed new title 9 regs um are
roll backs to prior to
2018 I'm not sure if they all are um I
haven't done a side by side but some of
them uh definitely are roll backs thank
you so at this time I'm
gonna call forward uh from the
University system uh Tom
Cronin
good morning Mr chairman M committee uh
Tom Cronin I'm the uh executive director
of government relations for the
University system good to be with you
all this morning uh so usnh is signed in
in opposition to House Bill 1288 as
introduced our biggest concern with the
bill is essentially it is laying out a
one-size fits-all framework for faculty
students and student organizations
across the
university uh at present we believe we
have ample due process to protect uh to
govern our communities disciplinary
issues that allow flexibility and
responsiveness depending on the issue at
hand two really particular concerns we
have first uh at present our uh
significant portion of our tenur faculty
uh and then portions of our non- tenyear
lecturer and adjunct faculty are
governed by eight different existing
collective bargaining agreements passing
this legislation would require us to
open every single one of those up in
order to come into alignment with those
agreements uh which would obviously be a
significant
challenge the second is for students and
student organizations uh House Bill 1288
would require comprehensive due process
for all disciplinary issues uh it
require the same process for minor
infractions that could lead to a warning
as it would for more serious infractions
that could lead to a student being
suspended or expelled from the
University
we certainly don't view uh you know
major punishments like that as a a minor
thing that we would do without ensuring
that our students have ample due process
an opportunity to understand what the
complaints against them are the
opportunity to question those to work
through a system uh before a final
decision is made uh so in our opinion we
believe the way that we currently
operate in terms of our due process
rights to protect in some cases property
rights of our students and in some cases
our faculty are are well established and
and are working fine for the University
system as drafted we're concerned that
this would increase the number of
hearings that we have to go through each
year from around 80 uh across the system
to more than 3,000 uh there is a fiscal
note attached here that would be largely
due to the additional manour the
additional investigators the additional
volunteers we need to go through all of
those hearings that could range
somewhere between1 and $2 million in
additional expenses a year um so those
are some our biggest concerns we had
however understanding obviously the the
views of the sponsors if the committee
is interested in moving forward uh we
had a few suggestions on amendments one
you could exclude employees governed by
collective bargaining agreements that
certainly handles one of the big
concerns on uh represented faculty uh
those folks do have clear disciplinary
processes built into those contracts
that are designed to protect them and
their property rights the second would
be to remove the word reprimand from the
definition of disciplinary proceedings
reprimand is not defined anywhere in the
bill but the way we would view it is
you're treating again you know to use an
example that's prevalent on a college
campus uh a 20-year-old student caught
with a beer can is being treated the
same way as a student who could be
potentially facing expulsion from the
University if we were able to find
either a strong definition for reprimand
to sort of suggest like it is a uh an
activity that you know is facing a
severe punishment uh or just simply
remove reprimand and be clear that the
bill only only involves those most
serious cases that could involve
somebody being removed from the
University uh third uh representative
luno sort of got to this we would strike
uh the language or has sought
recognition or approval from as written
now you're sort of giving a right to a
student organization that hasn't been
established um so there's no difference
in that case between a recognized
student org and an unrecognized student
org and then similar um right now the
definition or the protection for student
organ organization suggests that they'd
be deprived either temporarily or
permanently of any rights or privileges
uh we would ask you again to sort of be
clear that this is a more significant uh
you know punishment that they'd be
facing uh potentially organizational
suspension dis dismissal Etc that's said
we so we think those amendments if we
able to work through something like that
certainly reduce the likely
administrative expense and burden uh
across the system nevertheless we we
would continue to argue that our
existing processes work for our
community and a one-size fits-all
uh mandate does not and I wanted to
quickly understanding certainly where
representative Cordell was coming from
in his testimony my understanding from a
quick conversation with legal council
before he had to sneak down to a
different hearing is that at least in
the first circuit where where we are
governed we are required and believed uh
we to a student facing significant
disciplinary issues does have the right
to cross-examine uh which I know is one
of the big questions as we we look
towards the new title 9 regulations um
and then there is a bit of a circuit
split just in terms of as a public
institution what our requirements are in
terms of due process uh compared to
private institutions so I'll stop there
and try and take questions thank you
very much uh questions from the
committee yes represent McDonald thank
you Mr chairman thank you for being here
today you mentioned that if this were to
pass you'd like some amendments one of
them would to be exclude um Collective
bargained employees or union
members um I understand there's two
unions here today so maybe they would
better answer that but how would you
estimate what percentage or how many
teachers are represented by unions or
would that exclude perhaps a large
percentage of teachers if that was
amended I want to get back to you on the
exact number a significant portion of
our faculty particularly full-time
faculty are represented okay and then
you mentioned um a followup go ahead um
you mentioned that if this were to pass
as is you'd have to to reopen up to
eight separate Union contracts to rework
those um representative cordelli
mentioned that there is perhaps proposed
changes to Federal due process laws
would you have to open up these Union
contracts anyway because of the federal
changes my understanding is federal
Title 9 establishes a floor right now
what is in our collective bargaining
agreements is above that floor and I
should actually to that thank you for
for also reminding me that I think for
the most part our conduct folks on our
campuses would suggest that right now in
most cases with the exception of
reprimands when it comes to Serious
infractions the due process that we
offer particularly our students is well
above what is outlined in the bill um so
again it's it's forcing us to pay
attention to every forcing us to have a
similar standard for every potential
incident across campus as opposed to
Major infractions that would result in
somebody being removed or temporarily
removed from an institution thank you I
got question then I'll go to your
representative Woodcock um Tom uh within
the K through2 realm where we have
certified teachers which is different
than where you are we also have a code
uh of conduct and there's three tiers
their
reprimand suspension revocation of their
teaching
ticket um within the the eight unions
you're talking about that there is
reference to this process uh is it a
tiered system such as that we have one
within the code conduct code of conduct
for a person that's certified or do you
have any of those that that may be
available for us to look at yeah I I
would like to go back and actually get
you exactly the documentation I I'm
going to venture to Guess that they are
different whether you're talking about
the you know the adjunct Union perhaps
at Keen State versus you know the full
faculty Union at Plymouth State um with
eight different agreements there's eight
different ways to sort of think about
these pieces okay and this I'm sure
would be sort of similar to what's going
on in the community college I don't know
you don't re represent them but uh we're
going to have Shannon Shannon had signed
up yeah so okay thank you represent
Woodcock thank you chairman lad you may
have answered my question actually your
last comment Mr C just just for my own
clarification uh when you're speaking
today you're speaking on behalf of unh
or of all the four years or of all the
four years three four year institutions
just State un Plum State okay just the
fouryear chair correct okay thank you
thank you Mr chair you're welcome
represent
leus thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm wondering why you would
have to open up
um the
negotiations with the unions when the
when the union contracts are you you
said Above This in most cases but you
don't have to for the federal when it's
above the federal what is the difference
between this and the federal our read of
this is it's very prescriptive
essentially um it it is very clear on
how we should follow what the certain
things we should do um and that is one
of the biggest challenges it is just
very prescriptive okay thank you further
questions yes represent bbon uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I'm just curious um the
prompting of this this bill um what is
your experience
and in Your Capacity have people
objected to the process that you
currently have in place do you have a
lot of complaints about that to my
knowledge and then since receiving the
fiscal note a few months ago and doing
the research on this I I am unaware of
somebody saying that the process our due
process is not working at the
University yeah I fully understand uh
the sponsors intention of trying to get
ahead of something that maybe coming
from the federal side but I I and I
didn't hear in the testimony that it was
in reaction to something currently
happening at one of our institutions
representative Ford thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question is
there a distinction in your process
between a written and a verbal reprimand
is one a matter of record and the other
not it's good question and and again
that's part of the concern we have here
is you know you know a a faculty member
perhaps telling a student you know you
need to start showing up on time or
there will be consequences is that a
reprimand were unclear versus sure if a
student is in violation of again let's
use caught with a can of or underage
like they would probably have something
written and put in into a file at that
point and there are steps you could go
to essentially Beyond you know
University probation for some limited
period of time uh depending again on the
severity of the violation and that's
what our biggest issue here is there's
it's unclear that there's any scale for
severity thank you
very thank you very much Tom oh
represent
Damon thank you how does the
University
um due process
system integrate or I'm thinking not
with the court
system so we certainly review our uh you
know student rules rights
responsibilities is one of the key
driving documents here regularly um in
the event that there are court cases
that would change how we've written or
uh Implement certain processes we go
back and adjust as a result again I
think our policies are strong and we
haven't been the uh involved in those
lawsuits but certainly as things are
happening around the country
particularly in the first circuit as I
mentioned uh we're reviewing those cases
and if we need to make amendments that's
what we do I hope that partially answers
the question not see any other other
hand here thank you very much I have
written testimony which does outline
those four
items like to call forward Shannon
Reed from just that she's in the
questions she's not sure he's GNA be
here this morning or not okay
okay good
morning I should know by now Shannon
Reed representing the community college
system of New Hampshire nice to see you
all um we've signed in an opposition to
this bill I am here as much in listening
mode as um testifying mode because I was
interested to know why it was felt that
this bill was was
necessary
um we have comprehensive policies of
course that govern both student and
employee disciplinary matters and then
of course for employees we also have
protections that are negotiated and
enshrined in Collective barging
agreements um I'm not aware of any
review of our policies or our practices
or our outcomes that have suggested any
inadequacy in our current policies and
processes again I I was interested to
hear representative cordell's
introduction to this bill referring to
some pending Title 9 changes um but
again those are pending and only affect
a a particular um piece of the a very
broad disciplinary picture so
um I am not an expert on Title 9 policy
or indeed our disciplinary procedures we
have pages and pages of policy and
procedure and and a lot of what I heard
in the
introduction are also part of our policy
for example the presumption of innocence
the requirement for timely
notification um for hearings and appeals
um the ability to call witnesses so we
have a lot of those protections
currently in policy this
bill would replace our existing policy
and processes and negotiated protections
um with a set of different requirements
in a new chapter of New Hampshire law
um
again that would require for us
essentially a wholesale replacement of
what we currently do with new practices
that would have to be learned and taught
and staffed and institutionalized across
our
institutions um where I can't say that
I'm aware of any problem that would
necessitate that significant and Broad
change um but likely the largest impact
of 1288 would be a significant increase
in the use and cost of legal
representation and and I'll refer back
to what uh Tom Cronin just said about
how this bill seems to Encompass
everything from the the most minor
offense to the most serious and
consequential offense so for example a
student noise complaint in a residence
hall um
um a faculty disciplinary matter that
might involve um attendance inadequate
attendance that would trigger as I read
it the same protections that would also
be in place for the the far more serious
offenses that could result in separation
or some kind of more um serious sanction
um so the ca to ccsnh could could easily
reach a million dollars a year I think
in my fiscal note I was um I'm informed
by my colleagues I was very conservative
in estimating what that might be but
given the range of sanctions that would
that would put into play um legal
representation it would likely be much
higher and and the anticipated scope and
the number of proceedings that would be
subject to these new requirements would
very likely create also significant
delays before decisions could be reached
you know you can imagine the range of
activities on a college campus and if
all these are now going to be subject to
a kind of an enhanced um
process then there will likely be um
changes in the timetables of resolving
these issues uh again we have
comprehensive policies um and and the
collective bargaining Provisions um
enactment of this bill would remove
these matters and these processes from
the purview of institutional
policymaking from the internal evolution
of the student code of conduct and from
the employee bargaining process um these
processes and instruments are designed
to be responsive to to um the college
context institutional student and
employee needs um and I I provided a
couple of of examples um where the the
inclusion of reprimand the Le letter of
reprimand that kind of low lower level
sanction um would would trigger the
provisions of
um I I think that most direct change
would be that the institution would need
far more involv vent of legal council in
procedures that now are handled um not
not not typically with attorneys at that
lower end of the of the kind of sanction
scale um the bill also appears to
prevent and this is sort of a a specific
and and um a a specific point that might
not happen often but the bill also
appears to prevent the institution from
imposing any type of discipline until
the proceedings are completed unless we
can show a substantial likelihood of an
imminent threat to physical threat
physical injury or damage to property
there's no allowance for an interim
sanction that might um be put in place
to provide for to allow the institution
to act out of prudence to protect any
party other than in the face of the
threat of physical injury or property
damage and I can think of a situation
where um there's been an
accusation that might warrant removal of
of an individual from the campus for a
period of time until an investigation re
reveals more of what actually happened
there doesn't appear to be the ability
to do that interim kind of sanction
while something is being kind of um
investigated and and figured out um I I
I'll just summarize by saying we we
believe our existing policy and our
ability to negotiate protections through
collective bargaining are the
appropriate ways to arrive at a
complaint and disciplinary processes
that are fair and sound um we are kind
of all waiting to see what happens with
time 9 um and I would want I would hope
to do a Fuller analysis of kind of the
conflicting or dep applicative impacts
of what happens on the federal side
before um something is enacted in stay
law so I'm happy to try to take any
questions are there any questions for
the community college system
representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much Mr Reed um I I want to I
want to sort of um poke at the um the
example you you mentioned earlier about
um maybe a a noise complaint and and you
know I think maybe anybody that's that's
gone to college or has had um children
in college have um have been aware of
maybe um uh you know a noise complaint
or two and um uh in
the I
guess with the with the policy with the
proposed policy that's before us right
now um if there were something like a
noise complaint maybe um you know a room
two doors down from my daughter's room
is uh there they're up late making a lot
of noise um and my daughter's trying to
study would
um how would that be how would the ra
handle that now and how would it most
likely be handled under you know if if
if you know you had to comply with this
sort of one- siiz fits-all I I I'm
actually not 100%
sure how that would be handled under
under this bill something like that
there would be certainly attempts to
come up with an informal resolution
right um a more serious but in the same
kind of universe type of thing would be
if a student propped open a door of a
residence hall to allow someone in later
because they keep losing their access
card or something like that that's a
little bit more serious um not so much a
kind of student down the hall type of an
issue but more of a uh more of a safety
issue um there is an attempt made to
come up with an informal you know
resolution to sort of mediate that I
think that under this bill that kind of
thing would be um you know the the
student could have um an attorney
representing him or her cross-examining
Witnesses um something that seems
inappropriate to the level of offense so
our policies right now are are are kind
of stepped along the spectrum of colle
activity and and potential sanction and
and we feel that that's that is the
appropriate way to address the range of
things that can happen on a college
campus okay thank
you yes representative
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming to testify uh given the Title
Nine changes are probably coming um is
this bill fixable I mean if you took
into account reprimand like um UNH was
asking and bargaining
and perhaps interim measures is it is it
something worth working on to um to set
the ground for that I I'm sure on the
one hand that tweaks or adjustments
could be made to the bill so that it
would be it would constitute of an
appropriate set of policies I think my
my one of the points I made earlier
is requiring the institution to hold to
to essentially replace an existing and
known set of of rules and procedures
with something new is in itself a a
major undertaking and I I would say
there needs to be good reason to do that
a problem and inadequacy and I'm not
aware that that there is in this case a
significant Gap or problem or abuse or
inadequacy in how we're presently set up
to handle disciplinary matters okay
thank you Shannon I have a question to
not it to you um years ago we had an
issue with one of the private
institutions in this state where there
was sexual misconduct going on and it
came down to the
investigation do you do the
investigation or do you work with as a
result of that previous case we dealt
with an mou was put in place between the
local police in that particular
community and the University or college
um do you have something like that in
place right now to investigate the
situations may come up and where is this
stop start and stop between you doing it
and then the local authorities doing it
I would say that anything that that is a
potential criminal offense is reported
to local law enforcement and it's dealt
with separately in in in the ways that
are set up through the criminal the
criminal justice system
um likely such an incident would also be
a violation of a student code of conduct
or uh employment rules and it would
be dealt with um concurrently in that
way but informed by what happens in the
in the extra institutional or the legal
realm does does that make sense did that
does that answer your question well I
don't think we're going to be able to
get the answer in this one without a lot
more discussion uh in the case I'm
talking about we had the college taking
care of some of these issues which were
clearly on the other side of the coin in
the criminal area and um and the town
didn't know anything about it I'm not
familiar with the example you're I'm
talking about
Dartmouth okay and it had to be resolved
by the attorney in Grafton
County so I I just asked that question
see if there's something like this in
place where you know where this the
where the line is that you so there's a
due process afforded to the
student
and and if the student decides that if
there's a disciplinary action taken by
the college or the institution yours is
there a process where the student say no
I want to take this you know in a
different
direction yeah I'm not sure I'm going to
be able to answer that right now I I I
got you any further qu represent
Woodcock thank you chairman L good
morning welcome um just to clarify my
own misinformation probably I'm thinking
of Community College uh students for the
most part being generally a little older
a little more mature um so and I may be
wrong that I'm thinking different
different uh demographic of youngsters
or young adults that go there um what is
the ballp breakdown guesstimation on
High School age type students that go
versus older 10 I'm trying to think of
and that's just want in the second part
of that same question uh how many do you
have ballpark that we you actually have
residential settings if you may sure
thank you um I thank you uh the the
demographic of our students is in fact
indeed broad as you suggest we have
about um 60% of our students who are
under age 25 and 40% that are over age
25 Bas roughly um in residents we only
have two colleges right now that have
residential students nhg and conquered
which has about 300 students who live in
campus dorms and uh Lakes Region
Community College in theonia which has
kind of adjacent housing that houses
about 70
students and thank you just to follow up
to that residential number how many then
a non-residential you're looking at
maybe 400 finder there in your whole
system community college system roles um
how many actual roles that give my
answer right we I mean all in we serve
about 21,000 students a year significant
proportion of those though about 8,000
are still in high school okay and
they're taking dual credit courses
through us so you know roughly an FTE on
um a credit FTE of about 12,000 students
and under 500 are res very small number
hey thank you very much thank you Mr
chair you're welcome uh rep
laus would would the community college
need to revamp things if the federal law
does go into effect I'm sure there would
be some adjustments on the Title Nine
side okay thank
you thank you if there's no more
questions we'll call forward uh
represent
Len
I'm sorry thank you Mr chair members of
the committee uh um I I guess what i'
what I'd like to do I I think
representative cordelli sort of uh in
his introduction sort of explained
generally the bill but you've had a
number of questions and I i' like what
I'd like to try to do is is
respond um uh to the questions and I I
hope I'm doing this in in the in roughly
the order that they were raised there
was initially a question about whether
the definition of faculty member uh
where it
says uh means full-time or part-time
member and I think the question was
would that cover an adjunct I mean
obviously it would be up to the
committee if you thought it it shouldn't
my inclination was that it should that
it would cover it would cover you know
at a part that by part-time I meant to
include adjuncts um there was another
question uh uh about uh probationary
status and that's a very good question I
mean maybe that means that the language
would need to be changed my intention
was not to cover somebody that's on
probationary status because they've been
subject to some kind of discipline but
rather I meant somebody that I assume
that there's a process when you if you
first get hired that for some period of
time you're on you're on uh you know
you're on probation that's the kind of
probation I meant but but you rais a
very good question maybe maybe that
needs to be changed to say you know is
on a new high or some language like that
that's that that's what I intended um
then the the the
the other uh issue and I I very much
appreciate the representatives from the
from uh the university system and the
community college system being here
because I think they rais some good
points for example um the question about
reprimand um should that be covered I
that's they they rais some good points
on that I think your your point
representative luno about you know
somebody's the loud somebody's yelling
in the dorm or making a loud noise you
want to have invoke all of the full due
process uh areas here I I would tend to
agree if it's just something as simple
as that you know maybe maybe that's not
required so
maybe I I guess what I would suggest is
it may not be as as simple as simply
removing reprimand from the language
because my sense is that there may be
reprimands and then there are reprimands
if you know if you've if uh if you were
uh you know you were intoxicated some
night on a Friday night and you were and
you were making too much noise in the
dorms um and they you know they said to
you you know cut it out don't do that
again or you know you're uh impose some
very minor kind of uh consequence for
that maybe shouldn't be something that
is uh covered by by a sort of a full due
process on the other hand what I would
be concerned about is if if we if you
completely remove reprimand
altogether um could there be serious
reprimands that if if they were not if
they could be imposed without due uh
affording due process
that could be used
as um as a method uh to really very
badly D damage someone's reputation um
in other words if for example
suppose um suppose that there were an
allegation of some kind of sexual
assault which if true would be a really
serious matter that somebody should uh
somebody who would committed that should
be you know maybe should be expelled or
or or or whatever um but the but the
evidence was not sufficient to sort of
support actually doing that and so in an
effort
to uh in an effort to avoid having to
make a hard decision the institution
decide well we'll just impo we'll just
we'll just issue a letter of reprimand
here we don't have to go through all the
all the uh the due process standards
that that I think would be a concern so
I guess what I'm suggest in is maybe
there there is there is some Middle
Ground here where you might say you know
a uh a reprimand a written reprimand for
example that would be permanently a part
of someone's student file or something
like that I I'm I'm just you know
thinking off the top of my head here but
I would think that you it might not be
appropriate simply to remove all uh
reference to a repr man it's if you
could in some way sort of change the
language and I would obviously be happy
to work with any members of the
committee on this to to to make it clear
that what you were talking about is sort
of a serious reprimand something that
was pretty serious um and that could
have lasting sort of reputational uh
consequences on the person then it would
seem to me the person ought to be
entitled to Due Process now with regard
to the issue that was raised
about
um collective bargaining membership and
you know and the need to change all of
the of of uh collective bargaining
agreements that kind of thing um I think
several of you raised very good
questions to the witness who testified
in that regard and I think if you
listened carefully to what he said in
the end it seemed like he really sort of
came around to saying well really maybe
there really isn't such a big this isn't
such a big deal after all
because it sounded like most of the
collective bargaining agreements that
we're talking about and I have to say I
haven't I haven't reviewed those
collective bargaining agreements I don't
know what they say but it sounded like
if I was listening corre correctly to
what he said is that most of those
collective bargaining agreements
Encompass the due process that rights
that we're talking about here maybe not
every single one of them but but it
sounded like most of them do uh
substantially in uh incorporate those
kind of due process rights and I would
note in that regard please don't forget
to look at uh proposed RSA 188 j4 on
page three of the bill that indicates um
and I'm quoting now any New Hampshire
Public institution of higher education
May adopt rules regulations policies or
procedures that afford students student
organizations or faculty members more
due process protections that are that
are provided in this but None Shall None
Shall uh afford less due process so if
as I as it seemed to me um the Witnesses
were saying the collective bargaining
agreements do contain due process that
are basically equivalent now I'm not
saying that they might not have to
change one or two little things but um
but as as they uh seem to acknowledge it
would seem that they may have to do that
in light of Title 9 changes anyway so
would they would it might they have to
make some adjustments Pro perhaps but it
seems like most of the you know I I
would expect that the that the um the
people representing the uh the union
side of negotiations obviously are very
concerned to make sure that they're that
the people they represent have due
process protections so I would suspect
that many of those are close maybe not
exactly the same but pretty close um to
what to what is uh what is provided for
here so I I really don't think that
that's likely to be um a huge issue and
remember that there are there are many
people that are not covered by the
collective bargaining agreements that
could could easily be be subjected to uh
to some form of disciplinary action
um the last uh I I I the last point I
wanted to uh respond to and then I'm
obviously happy to answer any questions
you may have is the question about um
should this bill apply to to
organizations that sought
approval um and I guess I think I mean I
think that does that that that there is
a legitimate concern there if the you
know if some institu if some
group um sought a
approval uh for their group and for one
reason or another they were denied of
you know I I mean I um I'm not
suggesting that this would happen but it
could you know just take take an obvious
example suppose that the that the The
Faculty at UNH says oh it's fine to have
uh the young Republicans Club on uh on
UNH on the UNH campus but we can't have
the young Democratic Club um shouldn't
they and we're not going to recognize it
shouldn't they be able to say wait a
minute what are you what are you talking
about we have a we of course we we have
a right to do this you allow or suppose
you know to maybe maybe a less subtle
example suppose the uh uh the you know
the the UNH group every day uh every
every person for gun safety or something
they get recognized but there's a um you
know a a uh Pro Second Amendment group
that wants to be recognized and they're
not shouldn't they have the right to be
uh to say wait a minute you you can't uh
you can't do this you have we have we
have a right to recognition also so I do
think that there's a reason why uh
groups that are seeking
recognition um should have uh should
have the protections of this bill um and
I guess the very last point I'll make a
response to the the testimony of the um
person from the community college system
um about you know are there's
circumstances in which we need to remove
someone we we want to be able to take
some action like removing someone from
campus before there's a
hearing uh I certainly can see
situations where that might be
appropriate but it would seem to me that
it would be that in the circumstances in
which it would be appropriate there
needs to be some basis of saying there's
some kind of you know it's dangerous to
keep this person on campus um and I
think that the the exception for that is
uh is contained in the bill if there's
If there really is some a basis for
believing that there's some physical
danger to the to other students or
faculty or whatever um or some danger to
property of course the the the
institution should be able to uh to
remove the student before year but if
that's not the case your M just went off
well I'm sorry but if that's not the
case then I don't think um that they
should be able to you know I think that
the student should be afforded the
hearing first so with with that um I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
very much representa representative
beler thank you Mr jiren thank you for
being here for this testimony thank you
for presenting this bill uh on the whole
I certainly agree with the concept maybe
a few portions could use cleaning up I
have a couple concerns I hope you could
speak to um however page two lines 15
and
16 uh the right against self
incrimination except that invocation of
this right May afford a basis for the
decision maker to draw an adverse
inference against the person who does do
you think there might be cause there for
concern that there could become a
coercive environment for proceedings or
investigation if there is allowed to be
a negative infant drawn from somebody
invoking their right to remain silent
well you know what I would say I I put
that in because remember these these
proceedings are not criminal are not
criminal proceedings it's a u these are
you know for a lack of a better term
these would fall under the the broad
General category of civil kind of
sanctions that would be imposed and
there is a sort of recognized body of
case law that says in the civil law
context a a person still has the right
to invoke the privilege of
self-incrimination because to because
potentially there could be a criminal
you know criminal charge could be
brought but in the Civil context it is
generally uh permissible for um the
FactFinder to draw an adverse inference
and so that's why I put that
in is there
some potential for
coercion
you know I I suppose you could make that
argument I would tend to think that it
might you know that on the whole um it
it's not this is not a bad idea I guess
that's the way I'd answer thank you and
if I if I may real uh real quick because
that was the perfect segue into the the
other question I had and I'm not sure
it's specifically addressed in here I'm
hoping you can speak to whether or not
it would touch on it we've seen I have
seen elsewhere um and our chairman
brought up an example of this um the
idea of a criminal allegation being
adjudicated at a uh at a college
obviously there's colleges exist in this
gray area where they have to have
disciplinary proceedings but they have
not been established as courts by this
legislative body so my my inference
there with they is that they may have to
take disciplinary action but they have
no right to adjudicate guilt in a
criminal matter so would would that be
something that this this bill has
anything to do with or if not do you
think that might be an appropriate uh
addition to this bill to preclude the
adjudication of guilt just guilt in
criminal
allegations well I think I mean the the
the only the only place that criminal
guilt can be adjudicated is in a court
um and so I don't think that you know
this there certainly could be
overlapping I mean you know Behavior
could constitute both a crime that could
be prosecuted by the county attorney or
the Attorney General in court and also
be the basis for disciplinary action um
in uh by the university system or
community college system um and I don't
think this is intended to cover criminal
conduct I and I don't think I don't
think the university system would have
the authority to you know to adjudicate
guilt in the sense of like you're guilty
and we're imposing some criminal
punishment
thank you yes represent
Cordell thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question it is again in
regards to that same part I had uh my
last question about adjuncts line 17 on
page one but this part it this uh ex
exception does not include a faculty
member who is in probationary status
could you speak to why you have included
that and um you've
already clarified that this is in
regards to a new more so a new employee
rather than someone who is on probation
for like doing something bad um are they
not also entitled to do process so if
you could speak to why you have put this
exception in there and if perhaps it is
not necessary sure I you know I um
certainly in terms of is it NE I mean
could you take it out you you and so so
that so that everybody including sort of
brand new employees would be would be
subject to the due process protection
yes you could um I put it in there
because I guess you know I I do agree
with the uh with with the prior
Witnesses who testified I I'm not you
know I I understand that there is an
Institutional interest in in limiting
the number of hearings that that you
know that that this can be a that that
impose imposing these requirements and
requiring hearings can be a burden um I
and so I I just sort of assumed and I
think my inclination I could be wrong on
this and maybe somebody would would
correct me if I am but for example even
in most collective bargaining agreements
I think that there is often a um an
exception uh that that all the rights
that that a a union member has don't
kick in until they've served a certain
period of time and so it was along those
same lines that I thought that it made
sense to exclude people that were you
know were new employees basically on on
probation but again do you have to do
that no you could you could cover them
too but I think you do you then impose a
sort of Greater burden of perhaps more
hearings on on the institution and
that's why I did not put that in further
questions represent luno
thank you Mr chair and thank you judge
for joining us this morning um in your
in your opinion um what are the problems
with the current University and
Community College
policies well I guess you know I would
say this I I think my understanding and
I want you to understand I have you know
I have this isn't something that I've
you know deeply researched but from what
I've from what I understand based upon
what I've read in you know various
newspapers various Publications the
university system I think the the the
state college system is generally not
bad in terms of compared for compared
for example to private institutions such
as Dartmouth where you know Free Speech
uh free speech on Dartmouth is uh is at
a premium uh it is less so I think in
the in the university in the in the uh
in the University system the state
colleges but I I as representative
cordelli
explained um there is a very great
concern I think that
um starting with the with the Obama
Administration and and what you know
bear in mind what what um the way much
of the of the
um the proposals that were uh submitted
and
implemented uh during the Obama
Administration in this
area um it's not even clear that they
actually were buy were sort of valid
regulations they would the the Secretary
of Education would send out you know
dear uh Dear John kind of letters
proposing sort of guidance that weren't
really uh proposed as regulations they
were guidance so your guidance is you
don't really um you uh you don't really
have to have much in the way of due
process when somebody's accused of uh of
having sexually assaulted someone else
that's not very it's it's much more
important to um to provide Comfort to
the person who has allegedly been
wronged than it is to afford due process
to somebody who's been accused and so
you had this
guidance um suggesting you should do
this and candidly because most of the
institutions
um shared the uh the the philosophical
Outlook of the of uh of the of the of
what was being proposed by the Biden
Administration most of them did they
adopted oh yes we're going to do this
and then when the when the secretary
DeVos came in and and and and change
that um uh institutions did some
institutions did adopt did you know
adopt what the what secretary devvo said
um imposing more uh more stringent due
process protections uh and now there is
this concern that we're going to you
know turn the clock back uh with some
proposals that have been made uh by the
Biden Administration and so I think that
having a state law that
says this is you can't do this this is
what needs to be done because there bear
in mind there is real real questions and
I think to the extent that these issues
have have been adjudicated I think in
particular there was a case from the
seventh circuit if I recall when Justice
Barrett was still a Circuit Judge um
that really raised questions about
whether the uh the federal government
had under the Education Act actually had
the authority to issue these quote
unquote guidance um
uh letters um but but the my purpose
basically was to ensure that due process
is protected
um in New Hampshire uh regardless of
what uh guidance or other uh proposals
might be issued by um this current the
current
Administration just quick file we do
have one more person to testify okay but
no but uh judge Lyn would be the person
of um ask this so so given what you just
um talked about and and in particular um
U very prescriptive due process
Provisions versus maybe less
prescriptive due process Provisions I
was wondering what what how you think um
you know maybe the comments from the
former president of Harvard um may have
um may
have may have been impacted by a more
proscriptive uh due process um
policy such as this how they may have
been I'm not I'm not frankly I'm not
quite sure I'm really I'm really getting
at at is there a point with which um um
with with which a prescriptive due
process policy would would prevent the
college president from being able to um
to make a a specific um call on um on uh
behavior on
campus yeah to make a specific call I
well no I don't I mean I don't think so
in other words if a if a for example if
a if to you what to get out what I think
you're sort of suggesting is this if a
if a college President were
to um were to take disciplinary action
against some students for example for
engaging in anti-semitic Behavior
please understand on the merits of that
if they in fact did that uh should you
know and should there be disciplinary
action um uh I I would obviously
depending on the facts I would tend to
say absolutely
but it's like you know it's like
anything else that it depends on the
facts and I don't think that the that if
the students say wait a minute I didn't
do what you've alleged that I did or
you've you've really overstated what
happened here I think that the students
you know whoever they are whether
they're you know uh whoever they are
should have the right to have their
their a fair hearing and so you know if
that if
that due process
always in fact it's meant to it
always uh restrains someone who who
would like to act right now and impose
their will it always restricts them from
doing that um and that's you know that's
that's exactly what due process is all
about it's to make sure that we don't
act precipitously that we that we find
out what the what really happened and
listen to and give the person who's
accused the opportunity to have their
day in court for lack of a better term
or day of for a hearing before you take
some precipitous action and I think
that's pretty important to do
that further questions thank you very
much representative thank
you and lastly Greg uh Gonzalez from
fire welcome thank you happy to be up
here uh chairman lad uh Vice chairman
cordelli and members of the committee my
my name is Greg Gonzalez and I'm
legislative councel for the foundation
for for individual rights and expression
also known as fire fire is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization dedicated to
protecting the free speech and due
process rights of students and faculty
at our nation's institutions of higher
education through throughout its nearly
25 year history fire has defended
students and faculty on all parts of the
political Spectrum we have also
advocated for campus due process
legislation in state houses across the
country we are pleased to see that a
campus due process bill was introduced
in New Hampshire this bill will enshrine
important protections for college
students into state law such as the
express presumption of innocence and the
right to active assistance of council I
hope we can all agree that before a
student is removed from the College of
their choice and possibly have their
entire educational careers ruined for
allegations of wrongdoing universities
must follow Fair policies and procedures
to ensure that they get the ultimate
decision right as many court cases
across the country have shown it is
unfortunately common for universities to
for universities to sidestep many of
these protections when they are not
expressly guaranteed in
law however this bill would benefit from
crucial amendments most importantly the
provision of the right to remain silent
being invoked by the accused can be
construed against the accused must be
removed since most of the incidents
these college um displ disciplinary
proceedings May overlap with potential
criminal law proceedings the choice that
remain silent and campus proceedings may
be advisable it should not cut cut
against students who may be taking
advice from a defense attorney this
provision is also in conflict with
existing Federal Town n rules which
prohibit institutions from drawing
inferences against either a complainant
or respondent based on their silence
during
cross-examination further We Believe
other Provisions would benefit from
additional Clarity or sub or substantive
additions fire has model legisl
portions of which have been enacted in
nine states in fact over the past two
years in Arkansas Louisiana and Kentucky
such legislation has been passed
unanimously it has been signed into law
by both Democratic and Republican
Governors I would urge the committee to
take a look at those pieces of
legislation and our model to shore up
this bill and ensure students in New
Hampshire have the best possible
protections uh thank you um actually
before I finish um uh we also had the uh
very similar concerns with many others
with regard to the word Rand uh in this
bill um so you know looking to making
changes in that um can certainly
invisable and something that we would be
interested in working with the committee
on as well uh for instance our Mall
legislation uh it focuses on um on
infractions that would uh result in
suspensions of 10 days um or more or an
expulsion um and we do that because
that's in uh keeping with Supreme Court
president in Lopez Vos which said that
in you know um situations where a
student's education uh could result in
um like I said a suspension in 10 days
or more or an expulsion that's when due
process is necessary uh so that's why we
have that in our U Mall piece of
legislation but of course you can do
much um go further than that of course
uh but we understand that reprimand is
certainly an issue that can be looked at
in this bill so much any questions
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much Mr Gonzalez for uh
for being with us here this morning I
was wondering if you could um uh you
know let us know currently how or I
guess where are univers our state
universities stand in terms of their
rating with your organization uh so in
the due process realm I would have to
really uh take a look at the uh policies
but you know um um you know off the top
of my head I can't remember any
particular issues with the current due
process um uh language I but I will say
that you know you for this type of of
issue you don't want to wait till
there's a problem right um you know
there are plenty core cases across the
land where there are universities who
thought you know they they came and said
that they were doing the right things
all along when in reality they were not
um you have cases where there's no um
you know there's no uh live hearing for
instance which actually this bill does
not actually have so that's another
change that we would we would welcome to
this bill was um an actual live hearing
so you would just have um investigators
take some statements and then they would
end up being the kind of Judge juring
exe executioner representative cordelli
mentioned the return to the single
investigator model which is possible
with these new tile 9 uh pending tile 9
regulations so um that could happen if
um if legislation isn't enacted um it's
not it won't be necessarily mandated uh
in the new tile n regulations they
usually say you know they may kind of do
this um but in during the like Obama
administration that's exactly what
universities were doing they're allowing
the single investigator investigator
model to go forward so you know while
there may not be any issues right now
you don't want to wait for students to
be essentially railroad out of college
for that to have for changes to be made
follow up yes Mr chair how about with um
the University's um uh ratings on um
Fire's um speech on
campus uh so uh
I we know it's high like fourth in the
country but we that's the next bill no I
I I understand that but but clearly
there'd be a relationship between um
your policies on speech and campus and
and your your policies with respect to
um to to what the subject of this bill
is so uh so you you it would be
inconceivable to have policies that were
180 degrees out of sync with with each
other uh on that so so just to be able
to since since since you don't have the
information on um and we haven't been
able to find any any get any testimony
on information about any current
problems with unh's due process policies
let's let's swing over to what what what
will often behavior that will that could
result in due process and talk about um
um that behavior and where where are um
university uh colleges
universities uh stand with respective
fires rating on that yeah so um you know
we're we are happy to say that UNH is
currently ranked number three in fires
uh campus free spre rankings number
three number three out of
246 okay universities uh rated now that
does not mean that they have a perfect
score uh their score is about I believe
72 uh so I believe um that's a c in most
uh grading scales so um I I believe that
uh anyone that's gain a c has certainly
has room to
improve they do a good job at UNH yeah
let's just put that in in the minutes
further further questions thank you very
much and with that this closes the
testimony for the bill we're on 1288 and
we will shortly get into the next bill
which
is freedom of
speech and see what we got
here
yeah anybody on the committee that has
to take a break do so and don't be
bashful doing they when we're having the
hearing you need to take a
walk we'll start this up in a few
minutes I think have to leave um a
little longer I um going through
the um I'm going to have to leave up
this
1436 and then
tomorrow I can
only from the legislative view advisory
counil yeah you just said put them
towards the end
sure James James James
James there he
is good thank you that
works are are you
good
[Music]
um
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um I'm Representative Bob Lyn
from wendam and I'm a one of the
co-sponsors of uh of this bill um and I
guess
um again I think the bill I'm happy to
answer uh questions if I can I think the
bill is relatively um straightforward it
is designed to uh guarantee that uh Free
Speech rights are
protected um in institutions of uh
public uh higher
education um and that um you know it's
designed to Pro uh for example to
prohibit the establishment of you know
sort of free speech Zone some narrow
location where free speech is allowed
but everywhere else it's not allowed
just as an example um it's uh it's uh
designed um to prevent
um
uh other sort of intrusions if you will
on uh on on uh free speech uh on
campuses uh while also allowing the the
institutions to maintain reasonable time
place and Mana restrictions that that I
think that that does have to exist and
it it is provided for in in the bill
um so with that I'm happy to take any
questions are there any questions of the
representative not seeing thank you very
much thank
you uh I'd like to have uh
representative papovich
Muller
would it be possible to ask to uh close
the you know discussion I would like an
opportunity to speak at the end rather
than now if possible I I can put you at
the it's been introduced so if you'd
rather speak at the end that your I
would much appreciate that yes thank you
Mr okay we' like to have uh next then
Lance is it kinzer yes sir yes thank
you well thank you so much my name is
Lance kinzer I'm here on behalf of First
Amendment partnership I have some
written testimony that like to
perhaps now I was here last year in in
February on a very similar bill and I
know the the committee is uh well
advised on most of this bill has had an
opportunity to hear testimony before has
had an opportunity to discuss the bill
so I'm going to try to focus really
briefly on just a couple of things that
um I hope will refresh your recollection
on the the purpose and kind of the
intent of the bill but also provide a
little bit of an update and my area of
expertise to the extent that I have any
is really on the Student Association
portion of the bill that portion of the
bill that protects the ability of
student associations to choose leaders
who agree with the mission and purpose
and agree to live consistently with the
mission and purpose of the organization
this issue has has resulted in a
significant amount of litigation over
the past several years perhaps most
dramatically in Iowa where ultimately in
2022 the US Circuit Court of Appeals for
the eth circuit found that uh targeting
of religious groups not allowing them to
choose their own leaders based upon
their the religious views of those
organizations um with such an egregious
violation of of wellestablished
constitutional rights that the
university administrators who had made
that decision uh did not have qualified
immunity were actually personally liable
uh in that case
for one of the groups that was involved
in that litigation and that's been
involved in in much of the litigation in
this area a and even angelical campus
ministry called intervarsity and I think
you'll see they weren't able to be here
today in person but I believe they
provided already some testimony online
and the point that I want to make about
this is that um in instances where these
issues are litigated um it's
increasingly the case that student
associations who are forced to litigate
over these issues are winning uh they're
winning in dramatic fashion and they're
even winning some pretty big judgments
in the in the University of Iowa case
the taxpayers of Iowa were ultimately on
the hook for a $2 million judgment
approximately that they ended up paying
out but in Varsity uh although they can
win these lawsuits doesn't want to be
involved in lawsuits it's a distraction
from their mission and what they're
advocating for and what we're here
speaking in favor of today is really an
attempt to limit litigation by
establishing clear standards that are
consistent with the way courts have more
more been interpreting what the
Constitution has to say about the right
of student associations to choose their
leaders um consistent with the views of
those groups and that and that leads me
to the the kind of update from last year
most recently there was a case in the US
Circuit Court of Appeals for the ninth
circuit involving Fellowship of
Christian athletes versus the San Jose
Unified School District now that's
obviously by the case title A K12 case
not a higher ed case but in that case
the ninth circuit sitting on Bonk as an
entire court went out of their way to
say we're going to go back and clarify
our circuit's precedent on highered
issues related to student associations
because the direction the US Supreme
Court's been going on this issue is so
clear and so the ninth circuit ruled and
I think this is really the key because
often times the distinction has been
that let's say we have a you know we
have religion as a protected class and a
religious group wants to have religious
standards for their organization a
religious campus ministry and sometimes
there's been confusion well is it
religious discrimination for a religious
group to have religious standards for
its leaders and unfortunately that's
kind of at the core of a lot of the
litigation and the ninth circuit
consistent with some rulings of the US
Supreme Court has said very clearly
recently in the in the the higher ed
context anti-discrimination laws and the
protections of the Constitution work in
tandem to protect minority views in the
face of dominant public opinion just as
it makes sense in that case for the
senior Women's Club to have all female
members um just as it makes sense for
certain clubs to require good moral
conduct of their members it makes equal
sense that a religious group be allowed
to require that its leaders agree with
the group's most fundamental beliefs the
ninth circuit revised their their
circuit precedent to make this more
clear my point that I want to make and
I'll leave you with this is that the the
Student Association portion of this bill
which locks in the ability of student
associations to have standards for
leaders it's particularly important for
belief-based organizations it's been
especially problematic for number of
religious organizations the design the
intent the heart of that provision that
17 states have passed including Indiana
unanimously including Louisiana where
Democratic governor signed it into law
is to avoid litigation to create a clear
standard so that um un so that students
don't have to retain legal counsel sue
their own universities you'll recall
from last year um that there was a a
group from first Liberty the Christian
legal society that came in and testified
about issues they had had at the law
school I believe you'll be receiving
written testimony from both of those
groups providing a bit of an update but
I'd be happy to answer questions I just
want to say I believe that what we have
in this bill is a codification of the
direction courts are rapidly moving on
what the legal standards are and that by
having this inst statute clear the
result will be less less likelihood of
litigation more clarity for
administrators more clarity for student
groups and it's really promotive of
pluralism and so that's why we're here
to speak in favor of it today thank you
very much I do have a question for you
yes sir um where does the First
Amendment start and stop here in regard
to True threats expression directed to
provoke imminent Lawless actions and
like likely to produce
it prohibiting harassment as expressed
directly to uh let's see prohibiting
harassment as defined in RSC 188 Etc I'm
concerned where does where does the the
line is there a line there where you're
you're you're the way you're expressing
yourself the freedom of speech leads to
Lawless
activity and and how is that addressed
yeah through the First Amendment so I'll
begin by saying that there are a couple
people who are going to testify after me
particularly the the person from fire
who I think has has focused more on that
portion of the bill and may be able to
give you a better answer but my answer
would be that the this area of speech
say in relation to incitement is an
issue that's been well litigated over
the years the courts have established
standards regarding um through a host of
cases and we really do as we do in many
instances look to the case law to see
where those lines are drawn and my
understanding of the the speech zones
portion of this bill not the portion
that I know as much about but my
understanding of the this bill is that
it's largely intended to recapitulate
language that courts have used that
courts are familiar with so that when
this standard is the standard that's in
front of them and these issues are being
adjudicated they're using very common
standards that and using standards that
courts are familiar with and so there
are some line drawing questions that
arise throughout this bill that's not um
you know in that's not uncommon with
respect to much legislation that gets
passed but I think the real benefit of
this legislation is that it uses
language it uses standards that are very
consistent with the way courts have
dealt with these issues in the past
continue to deal with them and the real
purpose overall of having this just
clearly in a state statute is as much as
possible to avoid getting to the stage
where we have to litigate because the
standards are are are relatively clear
as clear as we can make them there maybe
somebody else can give a better answer
to that question but that's how I would
respond thank you are there questions
represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair and and uh uh thank you for um for
being here Mr kinzer uh to in taking my
question um you just um um chair lad
uh was just um touching on page two
lines 32 through 35 which is the sort of
like the catch all nothing in that se in
this section shall be interpreted as
preventing uh public institutions from
prohibiting you
know restriction of
expression
um
uh that uh that that that touches on
true threats directed to provoke
imminent Lawless act stuff like that I
was wondering how come the um the
section on uh the ne the very next
section uh Jen 3 freedom of Association
and non-discrimination why doesn't that
have the same um uh same language so my
my understanding is that those
provisions on actually engaging in
speech would apply just as much to
speech that occurs in the context of say
some associational event as it would
apply any place else the the point of
the associational protections is not so
much about the conduct of the group once
they're recognized it's really about
what what's the process for the
recognition of groups and what standards
can universities have in place that
would restrict the ability of a group to
be recognized as a student Association
based upon their Viewpoint or the way in
which they go about selecting their
leaders and so my reading of the bill is
that when it comes to the actual conduct
of a group the way in which its members
articulate their message doing that on
campus the same standards that apply to
anybody else with respect to speech
would apply but the associational
Protections in terms of group
recognition are important because
there's been a lot of confusion around
that issue in universities across the
country that's resulted in litigation
particularly around the question of can
belief-based
organizations require their members to
share the beliefs that the organization
holds and courts are more and more in
dramatic fashion saying yes they can and
the hope of this provision is not to say
once you're recognized as a group it's
absolute cart blanch and you can engage
in um you know harassing Behavior or or
criminal Behavior at all nothing about
the association provision protects that
but it does say that a group that the
university can't look at your Viewpoint
as you're going through the process of
being recognized and saying because we
disagree with your Viewpoint or because
you we require your leaders you require
your leaders to share your Viewpoint
we're not going to recognize you at all
so I think that's the the distinction so
follow up Mr chair yes so uh so thank
you so take me through this then if
um if a uh if if if basically a student
organization shall not
be sure I uh shall not be denied um any
benefit and this is the word from the um
the phrase from top of Page Three line
one yes don't be denied any benefit or
privilege available to any other student
organization so any B benefit or priv
privilege that could be maybe you know
500 or $ thousand dollar worth of
potentially Student Activity fin support
maybe a place on campus to Sir to to
conduct um that activity and um and uh
you know in an organization that that
where all of its members and
particularly all of its leaders um firm
andhere to an organization sincerely had
held beliefs what if those sincerely
held beliefs were so aboring uh similar
to the questions that were asked of
President gay uh a few weeks ago down in
Washington um would the um would the
university then U still have to uh
provide that student organization uh
space as well as financial support on
the taxpayers dime so the law makes
a pretty clear distinction between
abhorent views and abhorent conduct and
one of the things that that I want to
communicate here today is the groups
that I'm here on behalf of are generally
speaking Campus Ministries Whose desire
to be on campus relates to um hosting
Bible studies involving being involved
in in missions projects involved being
involved in public service so the and
those kinds of groups um consistently
have been the groups that are engaged in
litigation over the issue of not being
able to be recognized as a student group
if you go out and look at the litigation
that's actually happening in this area
um it it's it's really not groups with
abhorent views that are are litigating
um because there there are all sorts of
disincentives to those groups forming in
the first place on college campuses but
the thing I want to really stress
is that going all the way back um to the
the early 70s during the the Vietnam era
the US Supreme Court had to look at a
number of cases involving groups that at
the time uh were were considered
important so for example the at least by
some people so for example the students
for Democratic Society um at the
national level were advocating for the
violent overthrow of the government of
the United States and in a case called
he V James uh this was a case out of
Connecticut uh a university there had
said we obviously can't have a group
that's advocating for the violent
overthrow of the government of the
United States be a recognized student
group on campus that case went up to the
US Supreme Court and the US Supreme
Court said you can't engage in Viewpoint
discrimination based upon the view they
hold no matter how much we may disagree
no matter how AB warant we may find it
to be if they engage in conduct that
facilitates the over throw of the United
States if they engage in violence if
they engage in harassment if they engage
in inappropriate conduct then you
absolutely are in a position to act but
to say they can't form to discuss their
ideas on a University campus simply
because we disagree with those ideas is
is contrary to the protections of the
First Amendment my point is not to
defend any abhorent group my point is
merely to say that if that kind of
situation were to arise the place that a
a radical group with abhorent views
would go to try to get protection would
not be this state statute they would go
to he Le V James a long line of
wellestablished US Supreme Court
precedent on Viewpoint discrimination
and where I think this particular piece
of legislation will actually be be
useful the kind of litigation that's
actually emerged around this issue of
having leadership standards is not the
radical group it really is
um relatively run-of-the-mill
belief-based student organizations that
have had to sue in state after state to
vindicate their right to have their
leaders share their viewpoints so that's
a little bit of a lengthy answer I
apologize for that but yeah although it
Mr chair it really didn't it really
didn't address the question the the
question is does do these groups should
these groups well would these groups
under this policy under this proposed
Bill uh be entitled to the same benefits
and privileges available to any other
group um any other student organization
so talking about benefits and privileges
such as here's
$1,000 to run your organization and
here's a room in the Student Union where
where where where you can meet that's
different than a group of students that
may form a group rent a house somewhere
off campus and live together and hang
out together uh but we're talking about
where the where the university
financially and through through other
benefits forun would would be supporting
a group and and I don't want to I I'm
I'm working on the four corners of the
bill not not the not the you know sweet
Center in the middle talking about and
fortunately we have some really good
guidance from the US Supreme Court on
this issue as well so in Rosenberger
versus University Virginia in 1995 the
US Supreme Court was clear that Student
Activity fee funds which is what we're
talking about here cannot be withheld
from a group merely because they promote
or manifest a particular belief system
even if it's a belief system that we
would find abhorent and again like so
much of this bill the intent of the bill
is to provide clear statutory language
that student groups can look at that
administrators can look at that
basically recapitulate what courts said
for a very long time so again um yes
this bill says that universities in
determining who can be recognized who
can have access to benefits that every
other student group gets won't engage in
Viewpoint discrimination but that really
is just black letter first amendment
constitutional law um there's many
instances where States I think for good
and proper reasons pass legislation the
intent of which is to essentially
Implement provide guidance regarding
provide clear ity around um
constitutional protections and that's
largely what this bill does it's
designed to prevent controversy prevent
litigation by providing clear clear
language on the face of the statute
that's consistent with what the US
Supreme Court has said about Viewpoint
discrimination even against abhorent
groups in in Healey what they've said
about Student Activity fee fund access
with respect of viewpoint discrimination
in Rosenberger and so um that's
essentially my but we're trying to
decrease the likelihood that students
are going into court to sue their own
universities over issues that never
should get to that point because the
precedent is
clear thank you we do have a number of
other cards here so uh if there no more
questions thank you very much and write
up uh Caleb
Dalton
welcome well thank you very much
chairman lad Vice chair cordelli members
of the committee do you like freedom and
liberty in this committee that might be
a rhetorical question but it was a real
question that students ask asked on a
public University campus just a few
years ago for asking that question and
passing out copies of the Constitution
without a permit those students were
arrested and I spent the night in
jail the answer on our college campuses
to that question shouldn't be
know after all the Supreme Court has
stated the essentiality of freedom and
the community of American universities
is almost self-evident even for
viewpoints that we don't like indeed our
nation's future depends on leaders that
are trained through the wide exposure to
that robust exchange of ideas which
discovers truth out of a multitud ude of
tongues rather than through any kind of
authoritative
selection but many colleges and
universities across the country fail to
meet this standard the speakers in that
case that I I mentioned should not have
had to be arrested or to go through
litigation to vindicate their
rights legislation like HB 1305 helps
present that prevent that for students
in New Hampshire's public colleges and
universities and it allows them not to
rely on the M of University
administrators and policies that may
change but rather to have a baseline
Reliance in the law by way of
introduction my name is Caleb Dalton I'm
senior counsel with Alliance defending
Freedom ADF Center for academic freedom
has been protecting College uh and
University students and faculty Free
Speech since 2006 we've had over 435
victories for First Amendment matters in
public schools and over 15 victories at
the Supreme Court since 2011 on behalf
of our clients I appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you today and
would like to address two brief points
what does HB 1305 do and why does it
matter HB 1305 will protect the
constitutional rights of students and
ultimately if the university is abide by
the Bill's requirements as you heard
from the prior testimony it may actually
save the state unnecessary attorneys
fees and litigations by establishing
this Baseline constitutional protections
it doesn't micromanage New Hampshire
universities but it does set these
baselines that every institution should
meet to protect free speech and free
association and it makes those permanent
not subject to the whims of changes in
new staff or administrations at each
different institution this bill simply
prohibits prior restraints on student
speech while also permitting reasonable
content neutral restrictions and it
ensures student organizations can form
around shared values it allows campus
members to speak freely and
spontaneously without red tape and
unconstitutional restrictions and it
allows them to choose who they join to
with to speak legislators in at least 20
other states have passed similar bills
the granite state with its classic motto
Live Free or Die should join States
across the country in protecting its
public universities as the marketplace
of ideas where Freedom not fear of
government restriction leads to
Innovation and intellectual flourishing
why is it needed in a state like New
Hampshire that's received a high rating
from fire at least two reasons First
Freedom is never guaranteed is not
passed down in our bloodstream absent
laws or litigation it's actually subject
to the whims of Campus administrations
which come and go second New Hampshire
despite its higher rating from fire is
not IM immune from the impositions on
free speech and Association that come
from fears uh from students and
administrators you heard last spring
from students uh represented by first
Liberty who experienced firsthand the
student bar association's discrimination
against them and the recognition status
that was withheld from them at Alliance
defending freedom I represented students
this last year as well whose
organization were charged extra fees to
host an event on campus Because of fears
that others might behave poorly that's a
prohibited heckler's veto and is
literally expensive speech not free
speech in conclusion the status quo at
many universities substantially
restricts free speech and Association
and it teaches that student teaches
students that government censorship is
the norm not the exception New Hampshire
should lead in repudiating this
mentality and show that it's not afraid
of Freedom it should take a step to
secure the future of Freedom through a
well-educated citizenry that appreciates
the value that Free Speech brings to
society through firsthand experience of
that freedom on their campuses commend
the committee for its attention to this
vital matter and before I take questions
I would like to just address one quick
uh matter that was raised by
representative uh lenu I'm
apology uh on uh page 2 32 through 35 uh
if there is any concern that that
section didn't apply to the next section
uh I think it would be very easy to fix
that by striking section and inserting
chapter nothing in this chapter should
be interpreted and that way it would be
ured that that provision applies to all
the sections within the chapter thank
you and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee yes
representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question um what
is
noncommercial um expressive activity uh
for example is is a campaign considered
commercial of political
campaign I don't believe so so that's
considered a non-commercial what would
be considered a commercial activity So
within First Amendment law there's a
definition of commercial expression is
that which either engages in an exchange
or proposes to engage in exchange of
money for Value so it's basically
commercial speech so you're selling
something or asking you know trying to
sell something on campus that has that
that has an exchange of money is that
value some some some courts have inter
red that to be Beyond you know so his
services so for example fundraising some
courts have said
fundraising um even for a nonprofit for
example that's not considered commercial
but they've said that is commercial
speech so I think that and some courts
would fall under that and my my second
question is um the last particular uh
section on on page three um 27 through
30 the
severability um whenever I see that I
always uh think that there must be
something in this bill that uh could
possibly be unconstitutional I was
wondering if you could point out uh any
section in this that that uh is
particularly
um in line for litigation or uh that
could be um declared
unconstitutional um that hasn't been
already I don't think there is any
provision in this bill that could be
declared unconstitutional it it walks
the it basically reiterates the lines
that courts have laid down over the
Decades of what does the Constitution
allow uh univers so it sets that
Baseline of what courts have already
said is the law and that's one of the
reasons there's benefit to passing it is
it sets that Baseline so it protects the
state from litigation in the future by
saying hey we're going to follow this
Baseline and that way you don't have to
fear litigation in the future because
you've already set that Baseline
established by the Constitution you have
a followup to that
be a third third question so if this is
it yes go ahead okay three strikes and
I'm out okay um so uh why put in the
severability law is that that that some
of this has not been challenged in court
before I so severability my
understanding is to generally included
in most legislation to my knowledge but
I'm not a drafter of legislation so um I
do I I frankly don't know any provision
on this that would be subject to a
constitutional challenge okay thank you
thank you are there other questions from
the
committee yes represent
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
sir for taking my
question as a former University
president I've been present at a lot of
demonstrations in which there were
activities which were perhaps by local
or state law illegal speaking
specifically smoke inss and does the
freedom of
expression addressed in in this
law continue to the fact to the point
where it enables people to legally
conduct a smoke in a
marijuana against the laws of whatever
may exist is that legal I don't think so
uh that's conduct not expression now it
may be there are a few cases where you
know somebody's argued om my conduct is
to express a message right and maybe
that's an argument someone could try to
make but I don't think under this
statute it's because of somebody's
Viewpoint not because of their conduct
so if the a Prohibition on on smoking
for example is a content and Viewpoint
neutral prohibition and this law
specifically allows for that type of
Regulation as long as it's content
Viewpoint neutral it's not targeting
smoking for example it's or a Viewpoint
of marijuana legalization right it's
just the conduct of smoking that could
absolutely be prohibited under this my
interpretation of this bill for sure
awful lot of college dorms are illegal
at the
moment okay we'll uh move on here um are
there any other questions thank you very
much um like to invite uh Greg
Gonzalez welcome again yeah thank you
nice nice to be
back uh chairman lad Vice chairman
cordelli and members of the committee uh
my name is Greg andales i'm legislative
Council for the foundation for
individual rights and expression also
known as fire I'm here in support of HP
1305 this bill guarantees crucial First
Amendment protections at New Hampshire's
institutions of Higher Education First
the bill would designate designate
outdoor areas of Campus as public forums
this would effectively ban so-called
Free Speech Zone
which are often small remote areas that
imperially quarantine expressive
activity to isolated areas of Campus
over 20 states have already enacted laws
to ban these so-called Free Speech zones
further this bill helpfully sorry excuse
me and um further this bill helpfully
and carefully defines the line between
constitu protected protests and un and
unprotected heckers
vetos New Hampshire Public institutions
of higher education have maintained
policies in the past past that severely
limited students speech rights for
instance the University of New Hampshire
had a policy in the past that required
student organizations to get their
flyers and pamphlets they sought to
distribute pre-approved by the campus
police chief that blatantly
unconstitutional policy was on the books
for some time thankfully after working
with fire to revise those
unconstitutional policies the University
of New Hampshire now receives Fire's
highest green light speech code rating
meaning it has no speech codes that
seriously Peril Free Speech rights I'm
also happy to note that UNH ranked third
out of uh 248 colleges and fires 2023
college free speech rankings now is the
time to statutorily lock in these speech
protective policies last year much of
the discussion centered on whether this
bill was needed if un is doing so well
why is a law needed I think in the last
few months has shown that commitments to
free speech at by University
administrators unfortunately can have in
flow many administrators have had
difficulties making clear to their
campus communities what is acceptable
and what is not often times facing
outside pressure to crack down on
unpopular speech at their institutions
at public universities including at UNH
commitments to free speech should not
change at the whim of whichever
administrator is currently in charge
instead is imperative that legisl that
this legislature lock in free speech
protections into law the bill also aims
to remedy the threat to freedom of
Association created by the Supreme Court
in clsv Martinez and sharply divided 54
decision the Court held despite its own
long-standing precedent of holding
freedom of Association that public
university may require its student
organizations to accept any student as a
voting member or leader regardless of
whether that student openly disagrees
with or is even hostile to the group's
fundamental fundamental
beliefs College democrats should be able
to require that members be Democrats and
the Muslim Student Association should be
able to exclude from its leadership
those who oppose Islamic teachings
Fire's view is that the Campus Community
is made more vibrant when belief based
organizations are able to organize and
unite behind their shared
beliefs um lastly I'd like to um uh note
something that was said earlier with
regard to uh the
um what regard to the TR threats and
then the incitement standard so that St
the standard that's mentioned in the
bill is the uh Supreme Court's standard
for incitement in brand um in the
brandonburg case so that's why that
language didn't there it could just say
incitement but it just says the test
right there so that's why it didn't
there um but yeah in conclusion uh fire
um supports this legislation and I
welcome uh any uh questions you may have
thank you are there questions yes
represent Tanner I just came and I am
taking over questions
thank you for taking my question um I on
these Free Speech bills I've always been
um wondering about the fact that if I am
a student and I was a student and paying
you know dearly for my room on campus in
a
dormatory um I used to you know they
would have uh prank fire drills and that
used to bother the heck out of me but uh
they those people were taken care of but
with these um you know uh protests
anywhere on campus uh do I have a right
to my privacy as a as paying for a dorm
space where I want to study and I want
to sleep from having a protest outside
my window at 2: a or 1:00 am. that sort
of thing uh uh thank you for the
question uh yes uh you do so uh laws can
have these um U neutral these time
placeat and man restrictions so as long
as they're you know content Viewpoint
neutral um those types of laws would be
constitutional so as long as um all
types of um uh kind of expression was
like prohibited at like those times then
yeah of course that would be that that
would be those would be constitutional
you know you would get into the problems
if you said well from you know not you
know from uh noon to 1 you can only have
this you know you can have any type of
expression you want and then from other
hours you can only have viewpoints we
agree with something like that that
would not be Viewpoint neutral right so
as long as uh those time place manager
restrictions um uh you know our
Viewpoint neutral um you know usually
there's there's not not an issue thank
you uh any further questions yes
represent L thanks very much Mr chair
and um and and uh thanks again Greg for
uh for taking my question course um
going back to the um the freedom of
Association part uh did the Supreme
Court US Supreme Court weigh in on on um
whether that uh freedom of Association
extends to receiving the the same
benefits and priv privileges meaning
financial support the thousand bucks
from the in public tax dollars and uh
and location to set up shop maybe in the
you know Memorial Union building um as
any other um group uh so yeah as the pre
previous um uh witness mentioned Mr
kiner um who speaks very eloquently on
these on these subjects even more so
well definitely more so than myself uh
you know the the uh the relevant case is
the Rosenberger case and yes you know if
they if uh certain benefits are are open
to um groups that you know you can't
discriminate based on discrimination so
you can't say you know the obviously the
easy one you can't say college Democrats
get you know all the space in the world
and Republicans have to stay in the you
know in a corner somewhere type thing um
so as long as you are you have that if
you're opening those those benefits up
to to uh student organizations you you
have to uh make sure it's done on a on a
neutral basis thank you further
questions thank you very
much thank you uh I'd like to invite
James
TBO
Jim
okay okay uh next one is uh Jacob
cofin thank you uh Mr chairman members
of the committee
uh my name is Jacob Coughlin I'm from
Derry and I'm here to speak in favor of
the bill um I'm not a politician I'm not
a lawyer I'm a freshman in college so
let's get that out there first um but
I've tried to organize different groups
in my community and at school and at the
at UNH Durham I ran into uh many issues
with campus
Administration where they would do
everything in their power to prevent me
from organizing there whether whether it
be calling them for days on end or um
sending emails in an extensive
administrative process they did
everything in their power to prevent me
from you know organizing like-minded
students which in my opinion is an issue
for anyone in New Hampshire you know
it's not a republican issue or a
Democrat issue
um so I mean that's all I'd really like
to address you know it was very
difficult to um to organize they did
everything that they could to stop me
whether that be requiring permit on
public land and uh things like that
thank you thank you um I have a question
for you what were you trying to organize
I was just trying to organize volunteers
for um a quick uh for a few events
that's all uh nothing really crazy can
you explain the events the purpose uh
yeah just free speech events with
different political
organizations so uh for example we
wanted to organize people for the
Americans for Prosperity um for other
groups like that as well just general
Free Speech
stuff further
questions yes well represent leus then
represent
Luna thank you for taking my question um
were you eventually able to have those
events or not uh yes I was but we had to
go through a very extensive process uh
in my opinion it seemed almost like they
were doing everything in their power to
legally prevent us from being there um
again that's my opinion but um yeah okay
thank you
than scary but I must have been reading
representative leak's
mind psychic representative
perinel thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for being here and um
exercising your freedom of speech to
come before our committee today do you
know of any other organizations on the
University of New Hampshire campus that
have had trouble organizing I seem to
recall an incident I believe from maybe
about a year ago um I'm not familiar
with any to my knowledge um but all I do
know is my own personal experience where
it took a lot more effort than frankly
it should in America to organize you
know a group of people to act in a
political fashion
um yeah uh I do have another follow-up
question then do you know uh if there
are other organizations had to go
through the same process as you had to
go through or were you being
discriminated against oh I'm not
familiar with that but in my opinion I
feel like I was being discriminated
against uh based on our viewpoints we
had um campus Administration be very
confronted or uh very aggressive with us
trying to prevent us from organizing
um threatening to remove us from campus
before we had a permit even though we
were on public land uh doing a First
Amendment protected activity So yeah
thank you gu represent Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for being
here could you tell us in more detail
what was the timeline between when the
process began for you to um have your
events happen and what were the
expectations of what you needed to do to
be uh
approved uh so I had to call multiple
times uh campus security campus
Administration calls emails things like
that um frankly I don't remember exactly
how long the process was uh ballpark
five six days maybe a week um and it
wasn't a holiday week or anything like
that it wasn't Thanksgiving that we were
trying this
so uh I don't know it was lengthly uh
there was definitely a lot a lot of
Hoops to jump through that felt frankly
unnecessary for again a First Amendment
protected activity on a public college
campus
yes what was the size of the event in
terms of the expected number of
individuals so it was just setting up a
table with two people and asking people
to volunteer for us um or to come to our
events so it wasn't like we were
creating a a scene we were next to a
walkway just talking to people so it
wasn't necessarily a uh like a large
deal
right represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here and for your testimony um
I think candidly we can say that there
are considerable political divides in
this country um and that is reflected in
college campuses we we've seen that so
my question to you is just a very
general sense is that your belief and
understanding that uh all groups
regardless of what side their on or
their Viewpoint are currently treated
the
same by the uh the
university uh personally I don't think
that we're all treated the same um I
feel like if I was there advocating for
abortion or a different I guess more
leftwing social cause I would definitely
be in a uh in a in a poor position or
sorry a better position than where I was
then uh I mean honestly arguing for a
more conservative standpoint or
Viewpoint at University where it's so
overwhelmingly and obviously liberal
it's really a tough position to be in I
mean and of course the university can't
outright reject me because of my opinion
but they definitely did everything in my
opinion in their power to prevent me
from speaking my mind and organizing and
doing other first amendment protected
activities thank
you represent Luna thank you Mr chair um
when you you you mentioned um that um
that you received some um I I guess uh
uh had some interaction with uh with
University Personnel during events um
were were you in violation of um of any
particular uh freedom of speech um
policies uh to my knowledge or at least
to my knowledge at the time no um they
what about your knowledge now apparently
we required a permit I'm not sure if we
actually did to be totally honest
because it was two people setting up a
table and in my opinion that falls under
the First Amendment um but they you know
they confronted us hey you need to get a
permit to set this table up they tried
to make us move locations they were as
difficult about the process as
possible so followup Mr chair yes so um
so my understanding is that uh UNH is
you know ranked three out of 200 48 uh
Institutes of higher education with
respect to its freedom of speech policy
so it likely has uh a policy that um
that U that consistent with this uh uh
bill um uh May um maintain an enforce
reasonable time place and manner
restrictions um and uh were those the
restrictions that were being imposed
upon you now that you are more familiar
with the policies I'm not necessarily
sure but I also don't see how 11 a.m.
next to a path a foot path on the campus
of a public university is really in
violation of any reasonable expectation
of making a public
disturbance we weren't making a scene we
weren't doing anything really
confrontational or terrible in that
regard we were there with a table asking
for people to volunteer for us okay
thank
you any further questions
thank you very much thank
you okay i' like to call forward um
let's have the university system up here
now um so if the chief wants to come
with you Chad that's
welcome
uh hello everyone and thank you for the
opportunity to testify for the record my
name is Chad
pintel with me here today is uh Chief
Paul Dean who is the chief of police uh
for the
UNH um we have written testimony that
we'll will circulate um here when we're
finished candidly it's essentially
exactly the same thing that we did last
year so rather than read it back to you
again uh I I've proposed to go a little
more narrowly and to address some of the
things that I've heard uh from the other
speakers so far um the first is that
this bill is designed to use language
that courts are familiar with
to um reinforce existing limitations on
what public universities can and can't
do around regulation of speech and um
university system has some concerns
about whether or not uh that's correct
so for for example um on
page uh
two at line uh
25 uh right before that it's it that
that there's the language that some
other folks have reference saying that
reasonable time place and manner
restrictions are allowed but next
sentence at 25 says that any such
restrictions shall allow members of the
Campus Community which as defined in the
bill includes not just uh students
faculty and staff but also their invited
guests which I'm not sure how Chief is
supposed to determine who's an invited
guest and who isn't but it's a very
broad definition um that those folks
will have the right to spontaneously and
contemporaneously
assemble one of the most basic time
place and manner uh restrictions that
are employed by public institutions are
permit processes um as I read this
essentially it's it's taking our ability
to require a permit out and so I
struggle how to reconcile that with the
idea that it preserves all reasonable
time place and man restrictions that are
otherwise available to us um and chief
Dean uh his office U is very deeply
involved with the permitting process I
wanted just briefly pause and let Chief
uh explain how permitting Works uh at
UNH um I'll just say from a policy
perspective maybe the most important
thing is it says in the policy that the
presumption is that permits are to be
issued we start with yes we don't look
for reasons to say no but uh Chief can
perhaps say
more thank
you I appreciate this opportunity to
address you the importance of a free
campus permit process and I want to
underline free there's no cost to this
permit in maintaining law enforcement
and Public Safety on campus the issuance
of over 300 to 350 permits each year
without complaints underscores the
effectiveness of our current system the
UNH Police Department believes that
exist permit system coupled with un
policies effectively educates both
oncampus and off-campus individuals
about acceptable behavior the Dual
approach ensures parity in educating the
community about what is deemed
acceptable behavior before an event
occurs by doing so we contribute to the
deescalation efforts reducing the
likelihood of Confrontation that often
require campus police or Public Safety
intervention the permanent process
serves as an educational tool and means
to encourage dialogue about behaviors
that may disrupt campus functioning it
is not meant to limit Free Speech but
rather enhance it by fostering
discussions on acceptable conduct the
process allows off-campus individuals to
be forewarned about potential
disruptions facilitating an environment
where conflicts can be avoided through
education and discussion the UNH
police's Comm commed to maintaining a
positive relationship with the community
at large however the ambiguity and
uncertainty introduced by this proposed
law risk placing the police department
at odds with the community as enforcing
a poly defined law can lead increased
tensions and potential legal
challenges attorney pel's concerns about
the law and the ambiguity leading to
unnecessary law suits as valid and we
should we should I share his
concern in summary the UNH police
supports no CA permitting process that
focuses on education and deescalation
rather than limiting Free Speech the
current system effectively balances the
need for Public Safety with the
University's commitment to fostering an
environment of open dialogue and
expression clarifying the definition of
materially and substantially disrupts in
the proposed bill is essential to ensure
that the law aligns with principles that
do not create unnecessary
conflict and if I would just try to boil
that down even further I think I would
describe how Chief and his folks
administer of the permit processes
trying to use a pretty good dollop of
common sense in balancing uh giving
folks access to to campus letting them
exercise their rights but not uh
unnecessarily exercising the Campus
Community not possibly running up
against violating campus policy or law
such that the event can go off people
could have their speech the university
continue to function um Chief also
mentioned one of the other pieces of the
bill that I wanted to highlight um which
is the the notion of a material and
substantial disruption um that is a
phrase that you see in court cases um
it's used to describe a public
educational entities ability to take
action against uh a speech and conduct
event that has gotten out of control
we're we're not required under the First
Amendment to allow uh actions that
disrupt our operation
so that phrase is a phrase that comes
out of well understood court cases
however um that's not how it's used in
this bill um the phrase materially and
substantially disrupt is defined in this
bill uh at page one starting at line
13 in a much narrower way than courts
usually use it um it talks almost
entirely about what is called usually
called The heckler's veto which is when
somebody else comes on to campus and
does something that prevents uh somebody
on the community from exercising their
right to free speech um the right to in
general the right of an educational
institution to prevent disruption isn't
just limited to occasions when a Heckler
comes on and tries to disrupt an event
you know what if what's being disrupted
is not somebody else's speech but it's a
nursing class what if what's being
disrupted is a counseling session under
the First Amendment we do retain some
discretion to act in those situations
again Chief and his folks use a good
dollop of sense in that and making sure
that rather than shutting things down we
try to make sure that people have you
know are able to express themselves in
other ways and other places of necessary
um so again I I we struggle the system
struggles to reconcile the idea that
this bill just clarifies and restates
existing law with the notion that it
with uh the fact that it appears to
restrict us from using some reasonable
time place and manner restrictions and
it uses some language in unfamiliar ways
and whenever you've got familiarity or
ambiguity how it all ultimately gets
decided is in litigation and litigation
is has a huge cost in terms of money and
time for the system um I should also
just finish by saying um we've expressed
representative papor is has been
wonderfully available to us um and we've
expressed sort of these concerns and
additional ones we have a we we
circulated to him a a proposed markup
that we thought could address some of
these challenges um I don't want to go
through the entire thing here because I
want to be respectful of folks time and
also their bladders um so I'll pause
there uh I'm happy to answer any
questions that folks have and a chief
May chime in as well in his areas of
expertise thank you very much and this
first one's for both of you um invited
guests vers uninvited guests hecklers
could be in both of those groups um how
do you how do you deal with the The
Uninvited types that are seen at one
protest after another throughout this
country that all of a sudden arrive on
your
campus is the permanent Pro process set
up to uh deal with this type of
activity so uh the permit would be
required of the organizer um presumably
a Heckler is coming in um to disrupt
that they ought to be separately
requesting a permit I I take your point
that many times they wouldn't um as for
how it's managed uh You Know Chief and
his
team managed that issue with respect of
very large events all of the time um
obviously just recently uh uh former
president Trump came uh and rented out
the Whitmore Center had an event um an
event that obviously had a chance for
disruption Chief and his team Managed IT
there was no disruption um I think they
again have pretty good Common Sense
processes in place to address that um to
your point though uh representative lad
of how do you determine who's invited
and uninvited for purposes of
determining who has additional
protections under this bill I think
would be very challenging thank you
questions from the committee represent
Bel then represent cordelli thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here um
you brought up uh an interesting point
about the time place and Mana
restrictions excuse me as involves the
the permitting process that you
currently
have uh I'm sure most of us are aware
there has recently been a number of
rallies protests vigils other such
things group Gatherings um on the UNH
campus some of which have made news
headlines um I'm not here to take any
position on the individual speech they
have that right but my question to you
is were all of those events permanent
events um by the
university I I don't have details on
that Chief do
you I'm not sure about about all the
events you're talking about but I think
the ones that you are talking about do
have a permit and and the permits are
free there's no there's never been a no
I've been a policeman for 39 years 34 of
them at the University there's never
been a no to it it's always meant to
educate to make sure on issues such as
how do you get electricity if you need
to use a a megaphone how do you if you
want to put something in the ground you
have to use Dig Safe that's a law we
talk about littering you know making
sure that they know they need to pick up
their things so that's that's the
educational aspect uh of those the other
part to that is is I have a limited
police force and so I need to know how
many people are going to be on our
campus so I can provide Public Safety
Services or bring in more people for
that so the permit posit informs but
when it comes to those those I think
you're talking about they were permitted
but I'm not sure of all of them that
you're talking about but if they came to
us they would have been
permitted and if I made a quick follow
up on that thank you that that does help
um so obviously it's great that that the
permits are issued freely and the the uh
they're not turned down but we also have
to look at the possibility which has we
we've heard elsewhere that there is some
perhaps unequal enforcement happening of
non-permanent events so in order to um
assess that and do our due diligence as
a committee would it be possible to say
um receive a copy of permit records that
have recently occurred so we can compare
that to Media reports sure absolutely
thank you I appreciate
further questions from representative
cordelli uh thank you thank you
gentleman for being here um uh I believe
it was mentioned um about the definition
for material materially and
substantially disrupts being unfamiliar
based on other Court decisions and so
forth could you specify what in
particular in this definition um causes
uh you a
problem it's the narrowness of it uh
it's the fact that that the only
activity that seems to be defined as
materially and substantially disruptive
is Mater is Con is our actions that
disrupt someone else's speech there's
nothing that goes to disrupting the
actual business of the University uh and
there are cases dating back to to to
Tinker in 1968 that stamped the
proposition that educational
institutions can take action to prevent
actual disruption on on their their
property uh last year we had I think the
same bill coming before us I don't know
where the if there are specific changes
maybe some dealing with the costs but
um did you have an opportunity during
that the year that we've had here to try
to address those concerns you've had and
is there any way to amend this to
incorporate the concerns that I see a
hand up down and back from the
representative okay I think I'll get my
answer but go ahead the answer again he
he's been very available we did meet
with him we did send around some
proposed changes obviously the bill is
his to to submit to cc's fit okay great
further questions because the next one
which you're going to invite up is going
to be the prime sponsor of the bill um
Valerie you have a question um it is not
a question but James TBO has arrived
could you please read his name to the
list of speakers okay James is back in
here well yeah thank you okay
okay so are there any more questions for
the University
system thank you very much thank you
thank you so we'll Skip and and get
James up here right now
TBO good morning Mr chair members of the
committee um my name is James TBO I'm
the chair of the New Hampshire
legislative youth advisory Council which
is a statutory Comm Committee of the
legislature under rsa1 19k I'm here on
behalf of the council to express my
support for HB
1305 um I think we all agree that it's
very important that we um ensure
students Free Speech rights on college
campuses but I'm
not I'm not so much here to talk about
the merits of the bill because I feel
like many of the other speakers have
already done that um I'm here to kind of
talk about what the bill is lacking and
that is representation and protections
for high school students so um I'm
speaking on this as a high school senior
myself um who has dealt with um freedom
of speech suppression at my school um
during the summer of my sophomore year
going into my junior year I wanted to
establish a chapter of Young Americans
for freedom on my high school campus and
I um my high school principal said that
he did not want to approve the
organization because he feared that it
would make people uncomfortable able and
I got him on tape saying that and we
threatened a lawsuit against the school
um under Free Speech grounds and we
ended up um getting the club established
um however with the current Foundation
of federal law that exists under I
believe us code
4072 um there um it's called the equal
access act and it basically says the
school is allowed to impose restrictions
on student organizations as long as
those restrictions are evenly applied so
they told us that we could only have um
one poster on school grounds we could
only we could not advertise via email
via School announcements or any of these
things that typically clubs are allowed
to do on campus um and they said they
could do this because they were also
going to start applying those
restrictions to every other club on
campus as well and they also um they
also strung out the approval process for
my club by 6 to 9 months
um so because there are none of these
Protections in place for the actual
establishment of these organizations um
it essentially suppresses speech and
it's I think blatantly unconstitutional
and I um but they're allowed to do it
because of the particular way that the
law is written so we would like to
encourage the committee to either amend
this bill or bring forward a new bill to
also address the concern of um High
School Free Speech suppression as well
and I'd have we take any further
questions on that regard thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much for coming today yeah uh like
to invite Ellen
Reed thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee I'm sorry for my anxiety I
am running late for work uh and actually
I am supposed to introduce the following
bill and I have uh managed to get
representative Hill to do that for me um
uh on behalf of Cam Kenny um so I'm just
going to speak conceptually I'm not
going to have time to take questions but
I was here testifying for a
substantively similar Bill last year and
I believe I opened my testimony last
year with a statement to the effect of
now why would a farle socialist
self-avowed atheist be speaking in favor
of a bill that's primarily supported by
conservatives and religious people and
what I said then is what I still believe
which is Free Speech is inherently a
liberal notion John Lock liberal
principles is a founding of our country
notion and it is historically a
progressive cause and if you need um
evidence look no further than the
protests against the Vietnam War on
campuses where at least four students
lost their lives um look no further than
the civil rights movement and the
protest there and what I said then is
that that somebody has to be the adult
in the room because the winds change
what is popular opinion today may be
unpopular opinion tomorrow and while
today it may be the popular opinion to
have liberal Notions and conservative
opinion may be unpopular I am unwilling
even though that benefits my talking
points I'm unwilling to risk freedom of
speech because tomorrow it may be the
other way around and I what I could not
have predicted last year when I
testified to that effect was how quick
the winds have changed because today one
of the most as you all know um
controversial topics on campus is the
situation in Gaza and what is the
definition of a Justified Act of
retaliation versus oppression what is
colonialism what is genocide these
questions are coming up and now it is
the unpopular leftist opinion that is
being threatened in many scenarios
perhaps not all the way across the board
but certainly that is of um something
that's weighing heavy on us
today so I continue to believe as I did
then that the way we overcome bad ideas
is to not oppress those bad ideas to not
suppress them because that gives a
talking point to the people with those
bad ideas that they weren't allowed to
say what they had to say and they were
unjustly being restrained now I probably
don't agree on a whole lot uh with the
people who are advocating for this bill
um but I will say that I need my free
speech protected even though I'm not
planning on going back to college uh I
need my free speech protected and so
therefore I believe in protecting theirs
um so I guess I'll wrap that up I can
only speak conceptually I understand
this bill has had some minor
changes I whatever you see fit but I
just want to Advocate as the token
leftist in the room um for the concept
of of the bill and I apologize it's not
like me to not be able to take questions
but I really need to go to work and um
again thank you for representative Hill
introducing the next thank you and good
luck getting the
work um lastly we will have the prime
sponsor representa papovich
Muller thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee I really appreciate
your time and and uh I'll do my best to
be reasonably brief under the
circumstances which may not be quite
brief we already spoke about this bill
last year and a lot of those things
apply so I'm not going to repeat
everything I just want to remind you
that I was born and raised in a
communist country and experienced the
lack of Freedom which leads to me
appreciating Freedom a bit more than
people who never experien the opposite I
also want to remind you that I've been
involved in education in one way or the
other my entire life my mom was an
elementary school teacher I taught for
living for a decade I served on the
school board I'm serving on finance too
dealing with the State education budget
I am one of the people who truly
understands education you know and uh
again the value of freedom of speech and
Association this is a nonpartisan Bill
its only intent is to assure that
everybody gets equal protection under
the law I don't care which side people
are on I don't care whether I agree or
don't agree with them I think all speech
deserves to be protected because when we
start picking and choosing which speech
deserves protection we are opening the
door to our speech being on the nauy
list somewhere down the road so we need
to protect speech for all groups whether
we agree with them or
not I am a consensus Builder I believe
in working you know to try to get a
general agreement I have a approach this
in a very Cooperative way I started
engaging with the college systems since
late 2022 and we've been in contact ever
since we made a lot of progress we all
agreed with the goals of this bill we
are still arguing about various language
items but nobody in this room as far as
I could tell disagrees with the premise
of this bill we were almost there last
spring when uh I was told that if I just
make one or two minor changes the bill
would be ready to be approved by the
universities and get brought by partisan
support unfortunately when we sat down
last summer the Red Line I received from
UNH which I believe there are copies of
it in the room if you want them required
extensive changes that were much more
extensive than I expected and therefore
we couldn't really agree on the language
as a result I decided to fill this bill
using the 2023 language it's pretty much
exactly the same as HB 516 with two
minor changes one the committee noticed
that we were inconsistent in using
student organization we used two
different terms for it the bill has been
cleaned so that only the word student
organizations are used and I added a
change limiting the amount of Damages
that can be awarded in as to 20,000 to
protect the university system from
Financial Risk other than that it's
really the same bill as I uh you know
reminded the university system
Representatives this morning I do remain
open to amending the bill especially
since this is a two Comm bill it has an
FN in the most optimistic scenario where
we pass it we still has to go through
the house floor twice it has to go
through here it has to go through
Finance I will continue to engage to see
if I can make the bill better even if it
doesn't get to the point where they are
comfortable you
know supporting it at least I want to
make it more palatable to them so I will
continue to work with that until you
know the end of the session and Frank
frankly if it doesn't pass I'll continue
to work on it until he
passes now a couple of things that the
bill is intended to deal with first the
bill prohibits Free Speech zones Free
Speech zones are um essentially a word
that is used to describe the ban on Free
Speech in most areas of the campus that
a lot of universities are using my
daughter graduated from RPI and got to
experience fand the firstand the
chilling effect of free speech
zones
the bill is also designed to decrease
the amount of times when students are
denied their rights and then they have
to go through a lengthy appeal process
and retain legal council to finally get
a resolution I want to give credit to
the university system for being quick to
resolve these issues once they escalate
through that process but frankly if this
bill was passed there would be way fewer
times when this will be needed I don't
want to be cheesy and quote Martin
Luther King for no reason but he did say
that the right delayed is a right denied
he was using it in a very different
context but the principle still applies
if we make it amazingly hard for people
to exercise their rights we are
infriging on their rights because there
are few people who have the courage to
hire lawyers and go you know towards the
university threatening legal action most
people will just want no trouble they'll
just comply and move on we really
shouldn't allow that to
happen the bill also clarifies that no
content based restrictions on speech are
allowed outside of a few narrowly
defined situation obviously this is
already um known from Court decisions
you know the Congressional research
service has a January 10 2023 report
stating that the Supreme Court
recognized that laws restricted or
compelling speech based on the content
have the potential to expel certain
ideas or viewpoints from public de
debate so the court typically regards
such content based laws as presumptively
unconstitutional is based on R versus
town of Gilbert in
2015 I've heard reasonably often that
hey if there are court cases already why
do we need a law going to courts is a
tricky
thing a lot of people cannot afford to
go to courts or are afraid to and
frankly you know you never know what a
court will do when you go to court and
I'll tell you stories in the hallway if
you want to know why I feel that way I
don't want to take the time of the
committee with that
but it is better to avoid the need for
litigation and this bill is designed to
avoid that also college students are
adults they are not you know K through
12 students who are minors and deserve a
different level of protection they are
all legal adults or the vast majority of
them so are the staff and the faculty
they have the maturity and skills to
handle hearing speech they disagree
with claiming otherwise honestly not you
know is a it's offensive to me because
it implies that somehow our kids
graduate high school without the ability
to you know reason and figure out who's
right and who's wrong we've already
heard that this year reminded us how
important it is for our points of view
to be expressed whether we agree with
them or not so I'm not going to go over
that to summarize the freedom of
Association part of the bill it does
really one thing it states that student
organizations must be allowed to choose
who can be a member and be allowed to
enforce their codes and con of
conduct the point of this language is to
disallow all commer policies which have
been found to be constitutional by
courts which frankly kind of ruins the
trust I have in the courts because I
have no idea how somebody can say that
your freedom of Association is respected
if when you want to associ associate
with somebody you have to associate with
everybody who wants to associate with
you if I have a chess club do I really
have to admit people who hate
chess obviously I'm choosing innocuous
examples here but how could it be that
we have a freedom of Association when we
don't get to choose who we associate
with and that's really what all Commerce
policies do and this is why I think they
need to be taken off the table I will
give credit to the UN system and state
that they clearly told me they don't
have them and they don't plan on having
them
anytime I just don't think they should
be on the table just in case that
position May ever change I think it's
our job to make it clear that's not okay
now to touch to quickly touch on a
couple of concerns raised earlier there
was a question on separability Clause
that's just general language we don't
expect any parts of this bill to be
stricken out but since you never know
what courts do having that type of
clause is just good practice in writing
laws because it it assures that only a
portion of the bill will be struck down
instead of the whole thing if such a
clause would be missing in regards to
disruptions to the campus as a result on
Free Speech again the restrictions are
defined in 188 DJ column 2 Roman numoral
2 they have to be clear published
content and Viewpoint neutral and
provide ample alternative means of
expression the existing policies do that
this just codifies the requirement that
any future policies do the
same there was a question in regards to
188 j24 which is the part of the bill
that says that nothing in this section
shall be interpreted as you know
preventing public in institutions of
higher education from prohibiting
limiting and so on and so forth I would
be more than happy to amend the bill to
clarify that that applies to the entire
Bill not just to a specific section that
was the intent and I thought that where
it was placed that was clear if there
is any conf Fusion over that really
applies I'll be happy to reward it
slightly and move it out of that section
and put it at the end of the bill make
clear that it applies to the entire bill
that's just easy housekeeping and I will
be happy to continue to engage with un
over any issue but obviously one of the
ones that was brought up today was the
permitting issue I want to work with
them toh see how we can help them
continue to do their
job you know to require a permit for
large events or in situations where a
permit is needed while at the same time
trying not to unnecessarily burden tiny
little expressive action activities from
requiring a permit and you know we seem
to have a lot in common there so U you
know I will continue to work on that one
quick
thing this uh hearing was scheduled on
January 9 and the announcement was made
on Friday and as a result of the really
unfortunately short notice some of the
people who wanted to testify weren't
able to make it and that that is just
how the calendar works I understand that
not everybody can get you know a lot of
heads up but since the bill is basically
unchanged I would appreciate it if you
would take the time to review last
year's testimony since it is clearly
still applicable it's on the general
court YouTube channel the hearing was on
February 24th of 2023 and the relevant
portion starts at 3 hours 59 minutes now
to conclude
I firmly believe that ccsnh and UNH are
deeply committed to respecting the
freedoms that the bill is designed to
protect the purpose of this legislation
is to provide a clear framework that
would benefit everybody everybody
involved State residents students staff
the institutions themselves and I do
expect that the passage of this bill
will lead to financial savings due to
avoiding litigation and you know re
reduced administrative costs and I do
hope that it will earn your support and
obviously I'll be happy to happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
representative are there any questions
yes representative luno thank you very
much Mr chair and and uh and there was
no doubt in my mind you were going to be
bringing this this back um because you
said so and uh and pretty much without
any changes um but um but going to
obviously I've uh spent a little bit of
time and actually quite a bit of time
talking with you about the uh the
provision for um for freedom of
Association and I question to you Dan do
you do you believe that taxpayer dollars
or or Student Activity fees should go to
support student groups that promote um
views like
genocide I do not approve of genocide I
that's not what the question obviously I
but I didn't finish yet I do not approve
of those points of view but I do not
believe legally we have a right to
choose which organizations receive those
funds or not they have to be treated
equally that's why the quote from the
Supreme Court on the content based
restrictions when we talk about Free
Speech the free speech that is deserves
the most protection is the one we
strongly disagree with I can give you my
list of people whose speech I really
hate hearing but those are also the same
people for whom I will continue to fight
for their right to express those views
because without them being allow to
express their views neither of us will
have a right to express our views once
we start going down that path so I don't
think there is any legal way to prevent
those benefits from being given to all
organizations if we intend to respect
our Constitution and our existing Court
precedence including the Supreme Court
so a follow up on that if I may so so
given that response then um uh would it
be fair to conclude that your position
would be that a student group that um
that that um advocate Ates for genocide
would not be in violation of um of of
any sort of student uh ethical standards
regardless of how much I would disagree
with their points of view when we talk
about Free Speech the Constitution is
clear the Supreme Court rulings are
clear there is no wiggle room there and
that is the painful part of free speech
representative luno that in order to
protect our own free speech we have to
Pro protect everyone else's including
people who we amazingly strongly
disagree with there is no alternative I
just want to make sure I'm I'm clear on
that the question wasn't about Free
Speech the question was about associ
Association so a group that Associates
would receive um a a group of a Student
Association that advocates for genocide
in your opinion based on your answers
would receive um taxpayer or student fee
based funding from the University system
um potentially um uh a room at the
Memorial Union building and not be in
violation of any any U student uh um uh
uh
ethical um standards I do believe that
probably they their ethics would be very
questionable whether they if they would
argue for such a about the
institution's um guidelines for student
um
guidelines I would like to understand if
we are talking about policies or
guidelines guidelines in my in my mind
policy right policies that attempt to
regulate the content of free speech are
likely
anti-constitutional based on if they are
based on content so regardless of how V
it is and obviously you chose a
particularly V topic to ask about
because you want to highlight you want
to highlight the you know more extreme
views that may
happen there is no wigle room in the
Constitution as long as those are just
views if those are actions obviously
they're violating every kind of law
there is but if all they do is hold
views with disagree with then yes their
views should be permitted and they
should be treated the same way with
everybody else now mind you universities
being a place of higher education I
absolutely expect universities to use
the potential that such views may be
expressed as a great opportunity to
teach their students on why such views
are so vile while at the same time they
have to be tolerated it would teach the
students both the importance of constit
you know respecting the Constitution and
also give them the tools to reject those
horrific points of view because because
here's the thing I come from a communist
country
right indoctrination was tried really
hard and there was no uh alternative
schooling system or anything you had to
go to the same schools who taught you
the same nonsense and I could rapiz for
hours over the political science and all
those fun topics they taught at the end
of the day people know what's wrong but
the only way for them to confront it and
be able to reject it is to be allowed to
hear it in the first place so they can
react to it it's like keeping kids in a
bubble and they never develop antibodies
to develop those antibodies to develop
the ability to reject those horrific
points of view yeah you do have to
occasionally hear
them as words not as actions and be able
to react and explain talk back and
explain why they are so horrific talk to
other people who may have heard them
those are educational opportunities if
we try try to hide our kids from speech
they may find uncomfortable we are doing
them a great disservice and we are in my
opinion failing as education as an
educational institution because we are
missing on all those opportunities to
teach them how to handle those people
are already out there if you hide them
you just let them speak in the corners
where nobody can confront go ahead so M
Mr chair I mean I'm I'm I'm really
talking about Association but you keep
going back to uh to speech and so so so
I I I I picked a um um you know a
condition that's clearly uh uh abhorent
and uh and a in a real Edge case uh for
Association for
speech genocide would probably fall
under true threats Express expression
directly to provoke imminent Lawless
actions and likely to produce it or
producing harassment as defined in the
RSA and I'm reading from page two um
lines 32 through
35 um of the bill so so I I it it
doesn't sound like like this bill would
allow for free speech of what I was
talking about but it would allow for
Association of groups sponsored by the
university uh for um uh that that that
espoused views uh such as J as long as
espousing those views does not break any
laws the university would have to
accommodate all student
associations equally yes thank
you yes represent
cordelli uh thank you representative for
bringing this bill back um I was
wondering if you recall um a month or
two ago there was a uh Pro Palestinian
demonstration on
campus um and um it receiv received
considerable attention I think there was
even um on some national news reports
and um it was objected to by many Jewish
students um specifically for chance of
from The River To The Sea which some
people say is calling for genocide the
University's position was that it was
First Amendment freedom of speech issue
um first question is would you agree
with that
decision
since this is a Content based question I
actually would support the university
stance that people should be allowed to
speak people should not be allowed to
act in those ways and frankly this
current political environment is one
that highlights again the need for us to
be able to confront points of view that
we disagree through speech the remedy to
bad speech is good speech more of it
than countering the points made in the
bad speech it's a tough
topic thank you um follow up to that um
there was uh the most recent discussion
right now has been about section uh 188
j3 the freedom of
Association um in your opinion um based
on the research you've done does this
section break any new ground legally or
is it reflection of what we have heard
described as uh uh court cases such as
the Rosenberger versus Virginia case
there is a um gay area in the RO in the
legal precedence today and I
specifically refer to the allc Commerce
policy that currently even though that's
a precedent that's likely to be
overturned at some point right now it is
still the law of the land that all
Commerce policies are legal and the
intent of that section the 188 j3 is
really to make it clear that we do not
allow all Commerce policies because of
the fact they basically destroy the
right to free association again think
about any organization you belong to
imagine it with a all Commerce
policy would it still
work any organization depends on picking
who its members are and making sure
those members share something in common
that makes the organization beneficial
to everybody and so on any organization
any club anything if you would apply an
all Commerce policy to it and anybody
could join would be useless it would
just be used for you know by the
majority to stop any minority from
expressing their points of view and from
having a place where they can talk about
topics that are not necessarily the
majority point of view so I would say
that definitely that section is needed
because right now the allomer policies
are legally still on the table and I
appreciate again the commitment of the
University that they are not going to be
they're not being considered right now
and they don't have them but they would
be allowed to bring them up in the
future if the points of view of the
administration changes and I don't think
that should be an option you know uh the
we got in this issue of freedom of
Association has just rung some bells for
myself when little confusion here
if we have a Greek Greek fraternity on
campus and it's an agricultural oriented
fraternity with the chapter requirements
that to be a member of this fraternity
you have to be majoring in
agriculture if Mr cordelli beside me
here wants as a student to come in and
join that he may be majoring in history
science political science
can that fraternity say no you can't
associate with us the intent of that of
that proposed legislation is to make
sure that any student organization has
the ability to choose who can join yes
and while I would
personally say that if they are really
interested in agriculture the
requirement that you actually have a
degree on it is kind of silly because
there are plenty of farmers who never go
past high school and they know more
about agriculture than most people the
fact is that once you start taking away
the ability of an student organization
to choose who it is a
member most associations are just going
to become whatever the majority wants
and we have to protect every point of
view I don't think you're answering my
question I apologize yeah it's a in fact
it is a fraternity down UNH right now
with this very issue that it's built
upon those which are
majoring in that area in that program
and
their their their life their environment
the the way they work with each other is
contingent upon that background and that
learning that they're getting through
UNH yes should we then allow that be
watered down other words I'm just saying
that I if if there's a
requirement that an organization does
require your saying that no you can
bypass that requirement and you can
associate and I don't think that's no no
no no I'm saying that the organization
any student organization should be able
to set their criteria and be allowed to
exist and be allowed to set those
requirements for entry if anything I'm
opposing I I'm supporting the rights of
any student organization to choose who
can be a member regardless of what their
criteria may be
because it's really what the freedom of
Association is all about the right to
associate with like-minded people that
want to associate with me I want to
associate with them so this would be to
protect that type of
organization if this legislation would
be passed the university would not have
the ability to go to them and say you
have to change your rules for membership
or else we'll take your chapter away
okay thank you further questions
represent Damon thank you very much has
the ACLU expressed an opinion on this
bill I appreciate the reminder I I knew
that I miss something regardless of how
long my original speech was last year as
you do know the ACLU did support the HB
516 um right now I'm still in
discussions with them because the
ACLU representative who was responsible
for this bill moved to a different
chapter and I just started talking to um
Jill Bonet about the bill and I think we
uh I I would right now they did not have
time to go through their process and
evaluate it but I did start the process
and I definitely expect that by the time
the executive session is scheduled I
should have a clear answer from the ACU
and if I was a betting man I would bet
on the ACLU supporting it because it is
essentially unchanged from a bill a
supported last year but at this point in
time they did not have time to reach a
decision so I don't want claim either
way but I am talking to them and I will
definitely follow up to the committee as
soon as uh progress is made there thank
you okay I think we are done right here
now um I'm getting eyes down here like
challenging don't stop it I I heard from
you representative cascaden and and uh
so at that with this I'm gonna I don't
have any more pain cards thanks and so
uh representative if you could work with
the university system if there I see the
changes you've made with the the the uh
organizations and the damages if there's
anything else you can come closer
together give it a shot absolutely this
bill doesn't have to be out of here till
February 15th it is an early Bill thank
you so we have 23 of them in this
committee that's why we have to move
quickly on them so I'm going to close
the hearing on
1305 and the hearing on the next bill
here uh will be at 1:00 we are going to
take a
break
yes
which ones are those we already
got why just want a crisscross one put
them somewhere it we ask later
yeah yeah yeah
okay we're ready to go with part two of
today's
session which is dealing with some bill
from the morning we're going to be
starting with 1657 which is relative to
prohibiting hazing at educational
institutions and we have representative
Greg Hill that's
willingly offered to produc the bill I
don't think I'd go that far Mr chairman
but um willingly willingly is the
operative word um so I will introduce
House Bill
1657 FN and let you know that I have uh
in my possession and maybe in your
possession now um it is um an amendment
that I believe replaces all or I've been
led to believe replace is all of the
original
bill and I have a prepared
statement um from the sponsor who is in
law
school um full-time this week and cannot
miss any but appreciate representative
Hill introducing uh 1657 for me and this
has taking questions but it's wrong
um are there any Pearls of Wisdom in
there there are
actually okay let's go so this says uh
this bill updates the language that
would that prohibits hazing at
educational institutions this bill is
similar to bills passed in other states
such as Washington Virginia Ohio and New
Jersey and with many other states
introducing legislation to move in
similar directions the amendment is a
compromise with uh University system and
administration members from UNH Keane
and Plymouth who met with me meaning um
cam representative cam Kenny uh met with
me to discuss language that would make
the bill workable in New Hampshire I
will briefly go over the amendment and
point out the substantial changes that
it brings to the
bill um page one until page two line 22
it offers straightforward
definitions the only significant
difference between the bill and the
Amendments is line 21 through 22 on page
two that defines student organization
which makes it clear the organization is
formally recognized by an educational
institution as there are examples of
unrecognized organizations that the
institutions cannot act
upon uh second one is page two line 33
Begins the section that implements
educational programs at the educational
institutions this section is different
and more workable than the original Bill
based off recommendations from the
University system and the
institutions in the amendment the
institutions are given the burden to
provide an educational program regarding
hazing initially the student could be
penalized for not participating by not
being allowed to participate in
recognized organizations until they
complete the educational training but
this could have a counterproductive
impact such as incentivizing students to
join unrecognized groups additionally I
realized that after the meeting it would
really not work in practice but as page
three line four to six shows the
institution would still verify what
students participate therefore this
language still provides an educational
program on hazing while ensuring that
student students participate without
prompting unintended
consequences page three line 17 offers
language that has to do with
institutions reporting hazing
violations after the amendment each
institution will offer an annual public
report on known hazing
violations the amendment adds the
requirement that the report will also
State the number or percentage of
students that participated in the
educational program I previously
mentioned from the last
section the last Point worth mentioning
is that this report will be included on
the institution's website as shown on
page four line
2-10 page line uh page four line 27
amends RSA 631 colon 7 which regards
penalty for
hazing on the amendment Page 6 line 8
makes it clearer when compared to the
original
Bill oh um page six makes it clearer
when compared to the original bill that
the intent for penalization is for those
who specifically engage in the act of
hazing this section specifies that
aggravated hazing which is hazing that
results in serious bodily injury or
death Page 6 line
9-10 is a class B felony Page 6 Line2 1
all other hazing is a
misdemeanor the last relevant section I
believe could use clarification comes at
page 7 line 10- 15 misdemeanors have a
one-year statute of limitations after
talking with the university system
institutions it would be beneficial to
have a statue of limitations at four
years so that is where the new section
comes from when compared to the original
bill
I believe the rest of the bill is
self-explanatory sorry again for not
being present to take
questions but representative Hill is
willing to take
questions as it is those who help me as
oh no uh help me draft the amendment
from the University system if any
questions remain please email or call me
and I will happy to discuss the bill SL
Amendment sincerely rep I'm Kenny
Durham ready for question have a nice
day Mr
chairman um I do have copies of the
amendment but I I believe you all have
them as well um I can certainly leave
these with your yep I can do that um I
think you're on your own yeah well we're
gonna Tom Cronin would you like to come
forward and explain the
amendment
not have a copy of the amendment though
I can handle that all right
perfect maybe there you go thank you so
much
you so good afternoon members of the
committee Tom Cronin uh with the
university system thank you for having
us in on House Bill
1657 uh so as representative Hill
explained a moment ago we did reach out
to representative Kenny when we first
saw this in the system uh just to have a
conversation with him about what his
intentions were and where he wanted to
go and then had a couple of very
productive meetings with them on just
how to make legislation like this a
little bit more workable for the
campuses uh with the amendment the
university system is strongly in support
of the bill we think it strengthens the
state's hazing laws increases hazing
prevention education in both
post-secondary as well as secondary
education which we think is is really
important um and then allows us to
develop sort of consistent reporting
requirements across the state um I I'm
happy to answer questions I do think
representative Hill really did hit some
of our key points I'll quickly reiterate
at them uh really one of the biggest
concerns we have was the original draft
would have prevented any student from
participating in any University
activities until they had completed the
training that is just impossible for us
to enforce on an open college campus we
could not in any way prevent a student
from going out and doing something so
instead we really sort of took the
approach that other legislation think
specifically uh the sexual harassment
legislation from a few years AG go takes
that puts the uh burden on the campuses
to provide a program of Education within
I think the first 30 days
um I we also talked with Cam or
representative Kenny a little bit about
the idea of you know reporting on the
participation in those just to ensure
that you all lawmakers are aware that we
are offering it we're doing our best to
ensure students are taking it and I want
to be clear too a lot of what we're
doing in this case is thing are things
we already do we already include a
module on training we already on
particularly for fraternity and sorority
websites report instances where they've
had disciplinary issues so a lot of the
stuff that's in this is just sort of
being aggregated into things we're kind
of doing already um let me see two
others uh the initial draft of the bill
had us reporting uh semiannually twice a
year the amendment would change that to
annual annual is also how we do our
current crime reporting clearly for
folks who have heard that before there's
also Federal legislation on this issue
that if it were to pass would require
annual reporting uh so our thought there
was just to align with those other items
and then the length the statute of
limitations is actually something that
came from the University uh not a lawyer
um the you my understanding is a a
typical misdemeanor has a one-year Class
B misdemeanor has a one-year statute of
limitations hazing unfortunately is a
crime that when it's committed
everybody's told to keep quiet and we've
unfortunately had instances you know
over a number of years where folks have
come in and reported something either
that they saw maybe were involved with
uh but after that year and then we've
unfortunately lost to the the ability to
you know pursue that criminally um
certainly still take them through
student conduct Etc but by lengthening
it to four years kind of creates a
little bit of more opportunity there to
hold folks accountable uh if they're
involved in this sort of activity those
are again the the three uh three big
ones representative Hill did mention
recognize organizations that was also a
helpful edit um but we'd be happy to
take questions I think thank you very
much uh Mr Cronin um I I have a question
that's not necessarily policy but it is
finance
did you or working with others within
the system or
Systems address the issue that this bill
could cost as much as
$400,000 uh so part of the FN certainly
in in drafting the FN was related to uh
the couple pieces we need on ensuring
the annual or the biannual reporting so
a little bit easier under the amendment
uh I think at one of our three
institutions we would need to develop
the module that would need to be offered
still so there is a little bit of
startup cost there so yes there
certainly is a little bit of added cost
to the Mandate for sure but we think
it's one that's worth undertaking and
was the University system or community
college system going to take that money
from their Surplus fund or are they
going to come from us and ask us I I do
not expect it will be included in our
state appropriation request next year
yeah maybe some of the other bills
representative Myer
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here what is uh my question is
thank you for taking my question it's a
simple one what is the incident rate
right now of hazing on the on your three
College Camp yeah I appreciate you
asking uh very limited uh thankfully
certainly you know you you don't want to
ever minimize the idea that there's such
a thing as minor hazing there are
obviously instances of things that
particularly as written in this
legislation would probably rise to that
definition um but in terms of sort of B
big incidences I think at the University
there's been one maybe in the last three
or four years uh I think Keen State
Plymouth state would probably say about
the same this issue of recognized
unrecognized organizations is in fact a
concern uh there are a couple of
unrecognized fraternities and sororities
at the University a couple also at keen
and Plymouth where it's a little bit
harder to sort of police the activity of
the group versus the students um the
other thing I would also add too is you
know in working on this with
representative Kenny and our team there
is still an issue of you know activity
that could constitute hazing happening
in clubs in sports in other areas too it
is not exclusively a Greek life issue
but again to issues that rise to
criminal complaints very very limited I
would say less than a half a dozen
across the system over the last three or
four years followup please a followup
would be is how do you um get the word
out you said you already addressing this
within the institution what's the
process you use to make this If This
Were become law how would you then get
this word out to students uh the way we
do it now and the way the bill speaks to
it is as part of your orientation
process so all students are involved in
orientation so it is just part of the
the training modules that a student goes
through during orientation if you are
involved in Greek life it's regular
training on that side um and then
similar you know again mentioning the
the sexual harassment legislation
similar to if if it becomes a more
prevalent requirement email social media
Etc to ensure folks are aware that it's
there and
required further questions represent
Damon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for helping us understand the
spell your remarks a moment ago about
the low incidence of hazing was that
specific to the university system or to
all educational institutions in new I'm
speaking for
usnh if I may yep I just want to clarify
the bill does apply to public and
private institutions and I think the
incidence is different it may
be representative beler and then
representative Ford thank you Mr chair
and thank you for answering these
questions for us um a lot of this stuff
makes perfect sense some of it seems a
little difficult to find it seems pretty
broad um so looking at lines um say 20
one and then 22 substantial risk of
emotional harm can you offer it what
page page one one one 21 and 22
lines uh substantial risk of emotional
harm
um how how would that be defined in law
would that would that include like just
anxiety I'm not sure exactly sure it's a
good question we I'll say we rais that
as a question we didn't have a great fix
for it in this first round and I I'll be
clear too we are happy to continue
working on representative Kenny's
amendment to to better clarify items
like that and if I may just one one more
on on that same uh line of thought line
um exclusion from social contact now
that I I can understand how under
certain circumstances that would be
interpreted rightly but also we were
just hearing before lunch about Supreme
Court and the idea of being a of student
groups being able to exclude dependent
on their own beliefs and alignment with
that group so wouldn't it wouldn't it be
fundamentally true that a student might
apply to a student group and not meet
the qualifications and by definition be
excluded from social contact in that
group I think we're talking about two
different issues in a in essentially the
criminal definition of hazing versus
potentially joining a student
organization thank you represent
Ford thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering a
little bit in asking this question
whether or not this is almost almost too
defined in some ways about the student
group thing or maybe not specifically I
am a former member of a college
fraternity and they did do very mild
hazing others did more extensive hazing
but the athletes also did hazing who
were not parts
of fraternal groups and so I don't see
any reference here and these were
Varsity athletes on each other and
sometimes they were very physical yeah
no so organization so looking at the
amendment page two line 9 I think is
pretty broad for exactly that reason uh
Varsity Club Athletics are
included okay that that just really
concern that's my concern 100% are there
further questions for Mr Cronin yes
representa dry thank you so how much
does this change what's already on your
books right now about hazing or between
what's on our books and act and how
we're currently
doing this not a lot again I think uh
for I forget if it was Kean or Plymouth
one of our one of the organizations in
the system would need to develop that
training module in order to come into
compliance they are already doing
training I think this would by doing it
through the module be able to track the
statistics things like that uh in terms
of reporting we already report to law
enforcement which is one of the
requirements in here in terms of
reporting publicly we as I said report
at least on fraternities and sororities
publicly on their Pages uh training is
already there
uh again the the change on the statute
of limitations gives us that ability to
report to law enforcement longer which
we would appreciate but in terms of day
to-day activity it would be pretty
similar follow up just real quick that
can you talk about misdemeanor again
statute of limitations so it changes the
time that you can act on it but it
doesn't if you report after a year you
wouldn't would you be able to go after
again uh good question for I wish cam as
a member of the Judiciary Committee was
here my understanding is a Class B
misdemeanor has a one-year statute of
limitation so we have had instances
where a student has come and reported an
instance of hazing uh alleged hazing
after that one year and at that point
reporting to to law enforcement there's
no value that we still work through the
student conduct uh process assuming the
student is still there the accused
student is still there we would work
through that regardless of the legal
statute however by extending the legal
statute of limitations to four years it
would give us a longer time to report to
law enforcement I do believe there's a
requirement in the bill that we would
have to report to local law enforcement
within 72 hours of uh learning of
alleged incident which is what we do
already uh it would just ensure that in
the event that it has been kept quiet
for whatever amount of time there's
still a legal Avenue there as well okay
thank you are there further
questions not see any thank you very
much thank
you like to call um
on this bill we
have Shannon Reed were you going to
testify on this
one
okay good afternoon I'm Shannon Reed
representing the Community College this
New
Hampshire excuse me I've been trying to
sort of toggle through the bill has
introduced and the amended version which
I've really just been able to take a
look at um um today so my testimony is
directed at the original version of the
bill but I'll try to kind of morph it
into discussing the amendment to the
extent I've been able to um review it so
we certainly believe that this is a
well-intentioned bill but we would
oppose it as as
introduced um and I'll outline a few
reasons and I I will say at the outset
that my testimony is going to be a bit
parochial in that it's going to be
specific to the community college
experience of hazing um but I understand
that this Bill also applies to the
public four-year colleges private
colleges and um the secondary level of
Education as well so we already have
well established policies on hazing um
including that any such incidents must
be treated as violations of college
policy and also a New Hampshire's
criminal code reporting requirements
already exist including reporting to law
enforcement and making reports publicly
available and accessible on an ongoing
basis U we we publish a a log which we
keep um accessible to anyone who wants
to see it um and this would be part of
that that said we have had no reported
instances of hazing in recent memory
going back for at least a decade as I've
been able to discern talking to my
colleagues across the
system um certain requirements of this
bill would necessitate hiring additional
Personnel these include implementing and
tracking the training program and
preventing students from participating
in campus activities or events and until
they complete The Hazing training and I
I understand that's been addressed in
the amendment I'd like a chance to take
a look and make sure that it does in
fact um alleviate um our compliance cost
concerns on that score um costs
associated with this bill would have to
be met by moving resources away from
other areas of of operational need um we
have a number of questions I haven't
been able to kind of review in enough
detail but the reporting piece of the
bill and of the Amendment um could be
certainly workable based on what we're
currently doing um but the specificity
in the bill might create some privacy
concerns where we have small
organizations if there was an incident
it might be it might be difficult
to um protect privacy interest while
still meeting the reporting elements
that are in the Bill we need to take a
look at that
um I'm sorry I'm I'm trying to kind of
go between the the the bill and the
amendment we had some questions that are
similar to represented bels with respect
to some of the language being um
potentially a little too vague and Broad
like Behavior which adversely affects
the health and safety of the individual
that's a very broad um phrase and that
could be in the eye of the beholder and
I could imagine a I don't know an
athletic um training regimen that
somebody felt they didn't want to do
because it adversely affected their
health and safety which may or may not
you know be legitimately the case so I
would want to just find potentially
refine some of the language so I would
look forward to the opportunity to
continue to work with the sponsors and
um my colleagues at the University
system to just make sure that the
concerns that we have that would create
additional costs that were not um in the
end really helpful um to the whole area
of of hazing prevention um in in a final
version happy to take any
questions thank you um in my reading of
this I'm on page
two sorry the amendment or the bill of
the
amendment page
two line nine where it says Romans 8
says organization means a club
Association Corporation order Society
core private club fraternity sorority
Varity or Club Athletic team etc etc
what about JV team what about a freshman
team um it it seems that this is only
going to be applicable to your varsity
team that's an interesting observation
it does seem to skip over from Varsity
to Club yeah I mean you know I think
we'd like a chance to take a really
close read yeah and the second question
I have and then I'll because just a
cursory look too or thought when we're
talking about private 9 through 12
schools private
Collegiate High uh higher education
schools and there's a cost to doing this
where is the money coming for those
private institutions or is this an
unfunded
mandate I think it probably would meet a
definition of an unfunded mandate if
this gets passed and there are costs
that have to be met uh I think that's
the case for any type of institution
yeah are there further questions from
the committee
itself not seeing any thank you very
much was there any body else out there
that want to speak on
1657 if not we'll close it right
now and in looking at this bill it's
going to take you know more
work and most likely some kind of a
subcommittee if we see the need to move
in that
direction so just some
thoughts
now the next one on the
agenda
is hb1
1450 that's a bill that I have um I can
introduce it right now we should be able
to get done this in about five minutes
and then get back on on schedule so
let's do
that 1450
okay we'll open the hearing on House
Bill 1450 establishing relative to
establishing a commission on higher
education
consolidation and I believe um we have
some materials being passed
out and
um it's all yours uh chairman lad thank
you um you're going to have materials
coming around and briefly I'll just give
you a little bit of explanation where
we're coming from the sheet you're going
to re receive has the first three pages
show the governor's executive order for
the task force which is studying the
Strategic alignment a public uh higher
education in New
Hampshire uh so I don't think there's
any need I think some of us have looked
at that before um but there are certain
tasks that this task force is looking at
and per uh already in the business
looking at the issue uh that the the
governor
addresses and the task force shall
consist of you can see on that who's a
member of that
commission and and there are certain
requirements or tasks which the
committee is asked to
do and those are on the second page of
the governor's um
executive
order there's tasks shall be A and
B
and C solicit input from V variety of
stakeholders which that group's proba
already doing the bill which I
introduced was introduced at the same
time this was put together the
governor's task force has all that has
to have all their work done and
completed by the end of
March from my perspective I think that's
highly unlikely there's just a lot to be
done and I'll go through a few of those
things so what we did is we put a bill
in I put a bill in that would be a
placeholder in case there are
recommendations you can look at the
title of it it's not about merger not
about merger at all it's looking at how
we can align this whole structure to
meet some of these responsibilities that
the the governor's order says we should
be looking at and my bill say the same
has same identical language in
it so the fourth sheet down is a
timeline in which the task force has to
meet you can see they've already started
we've already started meeting on January
5th and had in January 12th which will
be coming up this Friday and you see in
that in accordance that we should be
somewhere close to getting done in
March um it's of a a hope and a pray um
the next sheet down looks at some of the
challenges which we're looking at which
deals with Public School uh enrollment
currently and you can see from that
chart starting back in uh 20022 2003
school year going down to
22-23 school year what the trend line
Looks like in our state we are losing
students K through 12 that has a direct
relationship ship to what's happening in
the Collegiate level not just in New
Hampshire but throughout New
England to our
students more competition to get these
students you we're we're we're fighting
other schools like
UMass uh University of mass amris and L
Orno uh we're competing for these
students and then the next sheet is a
sheet which shows challenges of year
student enrollment projections you can
see on that sheet it looks like this
right
here
yeah you can see what the projections
look like in year
28 look at that trend line it's going to
get
worse that in fact will have a direct
relationship with tuition monies coming
in that in fact will challenge the
system to try and retain some of these
students which are leaving our state to
go to school elsewhere to keep them in
our state that's why we have to work
with the community college system the
university system together the community
college system with the the 2 plus two
program other programs which they
haven't learned including concurrent
dual enrollment get students involved in
it there hopefully they'll continue
through with the higher ed four-year
program there's many many issues which
that that committee is um tasked to do
this the next sheet down is a sheet that
comes from the community college
system supporting New Hampshire's
communities and Workforce 93 93% of our
students are New Hampshire residents
that's wonderful in the community
college system you see where we're
pulling from we're pulling from adults
in our community a student that's a
little older than it is for the four
fouryear system campuses through New
Hampshire serve communities and support
local employers and industries and
really tied tightly together with the
small business and business in our state
trying to adapt and mold towards where
we want a Workforce to be now and in the
future and as it was stated earlier
today I think uh uh Miss Reed uh talked
about 21,000 22,000 students in the
community college system you're right on
the money
um and and it's done through these skill
certificate
programs but we got of dat this you know
we talked about even with the fouryear
system of train transitioning students
from one to the other without loss of
credit without loss of time without loss
of money these are all tasks which the
systems going to have to look at and all
points to governance too the last sheet
there comes from the University
system and it shows you what the
enrollment of four-year college students
where they're going in our state you can
see the majority of our kids
56.4% leave the state then you can see
that
27.7% go to the university
system and privates are
15.9% this is uh from the uh University
system New Hampshire you can see the
enrollment changes which we which
obviously are
shrinking uh several wonderful points to
be looking at so we have a system that's
been very effective both at the
community college system level and the
university system level that's why I'm
not really supportive any kind of merger
but am supportive that we got to look at
how we're going to continue funding this
where we're going to get our students
how we're going to keep our margin in in
the profit range rather than having uh
more expenses than we are revenues
that's also reflected on a St State uh
sheet how to reduce the student uh
tuition costs uh if we want to attract
students to stay in the state we're
going to have to do something about
reduce reducing those
costs um on the other side you can see
the uh average net price of attendance
New Hampshire undergrads um in
comparison to those private Cent State
uh un PSU in ke keing state are down
lower uh you can see the cost there in
that right H Kong some of the
initiatives that we have to look at in
terms of this higher education study
committee are listed there and in the
risk areas of enrollment and facilities
and infrastructure when you have uh
seven community colleges and three now
four-year systems
we have a lot of facilities we look a
lot of uh Capital costs out there and
we're dealing with uh deferred
maintenance we're dealing with a lot of
issues we need to be looking at how
to operate more
efficiently and and and and uh while
providing an adequate not adequate but a
superlative education for those students
which are working into Pathways here in
our state so the bill is set aside as a
a placeholder to support the task force
that is currently looking at this and
currently the last meeting we had
represent Lun you're on that task force
we're looking at who are the
stakeholders that we have to get
information back
from Educators yes students yes
administrators yes um uh so many
different people are involved in that
whole process uh so we have to do a lot
of research and a lot of gathering of
information uh then move forward with
some solid recommendations and there are
those on that task force would like to
see some solid Progressive
recommendations rather than just kicking
the can down the road a little bit and
we've done a lot of that and we've done
some wonderful things you know the 1530
which was representative Ford's bill
here a few years back where we looked at
trying to coordinate the career Pathways
we have established 30 uh uh Pathways
right now of which 10 we have it
universally done now throughout but we
have to get those other 20 or closing in
on those as well those are just a few of
the things which were going to help us
create a more cost efficient system
so I'll conclude and I'm asking that we
just keep this as a placeholder until we
have to get rid of the bill and that
time we may know how to amend it with
some language of some kind so that we
can get it to the Senate so they'll have
it as placeholder as well if we act
because we're going to have to rid that
bill by March
15 by March 15 right so we have some
time there but if in fact the report
comes out from that group somewhere in
March by the end of March it's tight and
and so if we have some recommendations
to have to go forward that's when way
that are going to need some legislative
support we can do
it any questions for chairman
lad luno yeah thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you very much um Rick
for um for putting this in because I
think this will provide a good vehicle
for point of
order yes your point representative Luna
referred to our speaker by his first
name oh oh I'll representative lad no
that's that's fine you're welcome
represent Luna no worries so yeah um um
but um would you and I'm I'm not
suggesting that that we go ahead and
start amending this now no but uh but uh
but just as far as the title of the um
of the of the bill and the use of the
word
consolidation um and and you know maybe
a more something as as we do go forward
with it uh Commission on public higher
education systems because it really you
are correct and that title was put in by
the folks across the street okay and one
of the things I talked with them when I
was discussing that said there are some
things for consolidating for example uh
president Dean down at UNH decided with
his staff they're going to move the
athletic training program the only
athletic training program we have to
Plymouth State University due to the
wellness center up there and their track
indoor track so that was a consolidation
of programs he the program was put where
it was going to be more effective and
consolidating down to one one program in
the state there's areas where we can
consol we've done it with law school
absolutely and those are absolutely
things which we got to look at
consolidation is a bad word that has not
been a pleasant word for the community
college system they're here they think
wow we're we're going to try to
eliminate that structure uh no I I feel
all these campuses serve as specific
purpose and it can be done but there are
a lot of efficiencies to scale and other
areas that we can address to make it run
so that we can run with the capital we
have and and also be reaching out and
and and and educating students the way
we should be doing and are doing further
questions representative Casen thank you
um thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative my questions are really
just to clarify my understanding is that
uh the governor has issued this order
for a task force and the reason for the
bill is to ensure the task force does
its work I'm not really clear on when
you call it a placeholder I don't
understand what that means it's it's
it's not to ensure that they do their
work okay it's to if there are some
recommendations that come out of the
task force that can occur through
legislation this is the bill or the
process to carry forward the
recommendations that come out of that
task force understood okay thank you
yeah anything further and that's what's
been communicated with the college
presidents and in had a long discussion
with Mark Rubenstein over that and and
so I think we're on that same
page see no further questions uh thank
you representative and we'll close the
hearing on HB
1450 and we'll move on momentarily to
hb1
okay I got one card on that 1436 but I
need to sponsor yeah
he's
spor here
Bel we need a presenter Mr
beler let me introduce our state the
bill first please um we have HB 1436 is
relative to in requiring institutions of
higher education to maintain certain
statistical information on their
websites and so I welcome representative
Belcher to introduce the
bill good afternoon Mr chair members of
the
committee so I did not write this bill
so some of the more technical aspects of
it I may not be super useful like the
URL XML stuff but policy-wise I should
be able to do a fine job here the idea
of what this bill is meant to do is to
create trans transparency and openness
that is available to all persons both
prospective students members of the
public and people like us as a
legislature now we want to be able to
break out information we want to be able
to
know what kind of debts students are
incurring in various uh disciplines what
their job prospects are from various
disciplines um we believe that's
important both both for us as a society
because most of these institutions are
public they're publicly funded and also
for the students who can do
it now there was some consternation
about breaking certain demographics out
of this
information here's why it's so necessary
to be able to do this recently the
Supreme Court issued a major ruling
striking down the practice of Harvard in
their admissions process using something
that Harvard was referring to as
diversity equity and inclusion as a part
of their on boarding of students now
what the Supreme Court said is that they
by having different standards for
different people based on immutable
characteristics like race and gender is
legal they said that is a violation of
civil rights
law
now in order to actually know if
colleges and universities are living up
to this ruling we have to be able to
break out this information to be able to
analyze it for us as a legislature for
the public for openness and also for
those who would be interested in
attending these universities because
they have a right to know whether
certain people including themselves
might be subject to discrimination in
the process of being admitted or going
through these
programs and that's uh that's it in
nutshell I'll have you take questions
are there any questions for represent
belter yes represent Tanner thank you
and thank you for taking my question who
actually wrote the Bill or does this
come from an organization no uh this was
Travis Coran uh representative Coran
thank
you representative cordelli uh thank you
um I'm looking at lines 21
uh uh 20 and 21 um on page one of the
bill um average standardized test
scores um at the University level or
Community College level um what a what
standardized tests are you looking at
getting feedback on uh this would be
standardized test scores for um for
admissions that were
utilized
so um like an SAT score um ACT score is
that what you're indicating yes what
whatever whatever the college is using
as far as a standardized test whatever
they're accepting for the admissions
process and again this goes back to the
Supreme Court ruling where they found
that Harvard the institution of Harvard
was applying different metrics using the
same tests by race and gender which was
found to be
unconstitutional go ahead
um over on page two um lines four and
five you're looking for the employment
rate within the field of study within
six months of
graduation from the
program
um so how do you envision the um
institution getting that
information um if the person moves out
of state accepts a job in California how
uh
what
um how are you going to collect this
information employment rate thank you
that's a good question um I believe it
was the belief of uh rep corkran that
this would be done through a simple
survey process of uh of
graduates okay thank you other other
questions represent
Ford how do we account for things that
seem more
anomalies than we think going in the
example I have in mind is we graduate a
lot of people in
education and a lot of those people who
graduated education as it turns out are
ideal candidates for management sales in
particular and that people are hired for
their people's skills that they
developed in a program for teachers but
they're hired to be salese in industry
and how do we then say geez they didn't
go into teaching but why they went into
something else but how does that get
reflected in the numbers what's really
happening with those
graduates thank you for the question and
it's a good question strictly speaking
this would not track data from somebody
graduating from one program and going
into a job and in in what would
traditionally be considered an unrelated
field um it would only track those going
into a field that would be related to
their re
program thank
you other questions from the committee
represent cordelli uh thank you um
toward the top of the first page um uh
the institutions of Higher Learning have
to maintain information on a web page on
their website the institution's website
I take it yes um on lines 10 and
11 for that information You're Expecting
The the commissioner of the Department
of Education to specify the font size
etc for the web page of the
college no I don't think there's any
necessity to to specify it I I think
it's just saying that it has to be in
you know congruent to what is already
being used as a part of the website in
other words it just can't be tucked away
somewhere in tiny font but that would be
by the commissioner of the Department of
Education I'm sorry I'm not sure I
understand the question
the commissioner of the Department of
Education would monitor the font size
and so forth being used on the UNH web
page I I
suppose uh any other questions
representative Cornell and then repres
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um there's no fiscal note on
this and I can't imagine that it I
imagine it would cost the University or
the other systems a bit of money to do
something like
this uh point is taken I would imagine
there would be a cost associate with
available a website I don't know what
that cost would be or why there would
surveys and tracking like for the
University of New Hampshire every year
I'm sure there's a large number of
graduates so trying to contact all of
them will take somebody a lot of
time perhaps um to do a mailing or
something to that effect yeah there're
certainly would be a cost Associated I
don't know why there's no fiscal note
that certainly wasn't my
doing representative McDonald thank you
Mr chair and thank you for presenting
this I do like the Merit of this bill
but as other committee members have
pointed out there might be some little
details that need to be changed and I
can see a few other places myself but
how would you with a prime sponsor
considering what has been said seek
amending this
language if I were the prime sponsor
um frankly I I like the policy in it and
that's why I'm I'm signed on to this
bill the more technical information in
here is not my area of expertise so I
don't know if that would be useful to
amend or
not thank you represent
cordelli thank you one more that I I
don't understand um in here um page two
lines 15 to 18
um the University or college has to
maintain at least 99% uptime monitored I
guess by somebody or reported by the
college to to somebody but if they don't
maintain 99% uptime they lose their
nonprofit
status
yes presumably that's I don't know this
the the exact numbers that are sort of
incommon usage because again this is a
technical item and I'm not a technical
person when it comes to the the web
stuff but the idea would be that this
this can't be a usually under
construction kind of website that isn't
available to the
public okay are there any more question
repres
Damon are there other State University
systems that are doing something like
this uh I'm not sure there are
organizations like the national Clearing
House which
we we get information from them in terms
of uh six-year degree four-year degree
and I I'm sure that we have Mr Cronin is
also going to speak he he could convey
some of that to us because they are a
clearing house for this type of
information which could be available
excellent the national Clearing
House yeah yeah we we had a debate on
that down in Senate Ed one day I can't
remember uh when that was maybe 3 years
ago and where we pay dues to
it yeah yeah
yeah represent
Miler thank you for taking my question
I'm uh this applies to
all higher education institutions public
and private is that the intent of the
bill it applies to all nonprofit
institutions of Education higher
education okay any further
questions and the private stuff is
available if you look at the sheet I
just passed out earlier you can see what
the price of attendance uh average price
is for SE anoms for Dartmouth for
Franklin Pierce uh kobby Sawyer that
information is all available through the
Clearing House and so um there there
some of this data is available um but I
don't know to what degree sure and I
think the big the big point was to try
to make it more granular on a degree
specific basis what their what the job
prospects are how long it's going to
take to pay back your loans things like
that yeah and we have research too that
been on
restructuring where we know that 2third
of the land grant student population in
some of these colleges are attending 12
specific Majors all those other Majors
have the other third and so obviously
which is more coste
effective further further
questions thank you very much for
introducing
it Tom
Cronin uh good afternoon members of the
committee Tom Cronin University system
of New Hampshire so usnh is uh opposed
to the legislation as drafted uh
certainly some of the questions during
the opening testimony got some of our
concerns I at the end of the day I'd
suggest ultimately the bill would
require every institution of highed in
the state to develop lengthy dashboards
of Statistics that would be difficult or
in some cases simply impossible uh for
us to develop and manage and it's also
incredibly duplicative of efforts that
are already Ong goinging at the federal
level so second part first the federal
government has uh currently the
department of education's college scor
card uh simply just Google US doe
College scorecard and you can pull up
every institution of higher ed in the
country and scroll through really a
number of the statistics that would be
required by the legislation uh including
uh but not necessarily limited to uh
enrollment cost completion rates
starting salaries campus diversity uh
Etc and they do it in a very consistent
accessible format where you can compare
any institution to any other uh across
the board in addition to what's already
there uh literally within the last
couple of weeks uh the federal
government just finalized new called
gainful employment rules um and those
rules are going to require institutions
to also share data that will allow
calculations on debt to earnings and
really the financial value premium of
higher ed and the way they're able to do
this at the federal level that would be
very challenging for us is the federal
government is able to take the
information we report through ipeds
which stands for the integrated
postsecondary Education data system and
cross reference that with tax
information uh federal financial aid
information and other pieces of data
that only the federal government have
access to in order to then produce a
picture that consumers students and
families can look at when making their
higher ed choices we simply don't have
access to all that information in a way
that we could produce a lot of this data
in a incredibly reliable way for example
the representative mentioned uh
employment rate so we do uh across the
university system What's called the
first destination survey so we ask all
of our students um within the first few
months of their graduation how they're
doing in order to get a sense from them
how they're doing right and so we're
proud to say uh you know across usnh
like we are about above a 90% success
rate is what it's called so either more
than 90% of our students are either
working or pursuing F their education
within six months of graduation we
certainly use that in our materials when
talking to students but we also wouldn't
call it a uh you
know it is a a self-reported survey it
is not you know completely reliable data
that should be put against how anybody
else does that survey um in addition to
that starting salaries as I mentioned
would have to be self-reported would' be
incomplete unreliable uh because we
don't have access to their tax
information uh so really for us those
are the the two main concerns is the
federal government is already doing and
is mandating that we do a lot of this
work in conjunction with Federal Data
Systems and the stuff that sort of left
is left for a reason because it'd be
very challenging to develop it in a
reliable format happy to take questions
thank you very much are there any
questions uh Mr
Cronin yes represent
leus would there be any reason why you
wouldn't be able to just take that data
from the federal website and put it on
your website so that a student or a
parent who was just going through
looking at your website as opposed to
where is this information on a federal
website be able to just look at it sure
I would there be any reason no um I
think we do and I will say if you were
to poke through any of our websites you
will find a lot of information on
enrollment um I think we're proud of
most of the data that's up in the the
federal system and we do use it when
talking to prospective students and
families for sure okay y thank you but I
don't think it's necessary that we
duplicate that effort or mandate that we
duplicate that effort further for the
questions thank you very much thank
you
and Debbie Debbie Skiby is is that s c i
v pardon
me I
okay
everyone thank you for the opportunity
excuse me press the uh silver button on
there let me try again um thank you very
much for the opportunity to speak um to
this committee regarding hb1
1436 uh relative to requiring
institutions of HED to maintain certain
statistical information on their website
I'm Debbie skiri and I serve as the
president of New Hampshire College
University Council and we respectfully
request that you oppose this legislation
the NHC um as many of you know is a
nonprofit Consortium of public and
private institutions of higher education
in our state and these institutions are
recognized and highly regarded for their
outstanding teaching research and
community service activities they serve
as major centers of activity and they
vital to the economic development of the
community in our state um New Hampshire
College University member colleges and
universities are deeply concerned about
college costs student debt and the
extent that our students are
prepared to find their way in our
state's economy our institutions are
committed to working with students and
parents to help them identify the best
institutional fit for their college
education transparency and openness
around College pricing is critical
as well as is alerting students to
programs that could potentially leave
them in debt we appreciate the sentiment
behind 1436 to ensure students and
parents have important information about
college costs however we are concerned
that hb1 1436 is duplicative of nearly
identif identical Federal Regulation by
the US Department of Education scheduled
to go into effect as early as July the
1st 2024 of this year and therefore
creating additional
costs this regulation is known as the
financial value transparency framework
it's mouthful um this regulation will
cover all programs that participate in
title four which is also known as
federal student aid financial aid and it
will include the following statistics so
debt to ear sorry debt to earnings
measures that reflect the affordability
of loan payments for graduates and
earnings premium measure that evaluates
whether program graduates are likely to
be able to earn more than a typical high
school graduate the published length of
each program the total costs of tuition
fees books supplies and equipment
students likely earnings after
graduation and also the median student
loan debt the published timeline
indicates that institutions of high Ed
will be required to start reporting July
31st again of this year and these data
points will be released as early as
2025 um the goal of this the financial
value transparency framework is to
empower students and their families to
make informed Apples to Apples decisions
among all colleges and universities
across our nation so the idea is that
there would be one spot where people
could sort of like look right straight
across and compare program by program on
all of these different
metrics passing 1436 would further
increase College costs as institutions
would need to hire staff to monitor
their website um given what's already
been pointed out the really harsh
penalties proposed in this spell
including loss of nonprofit status and
the right to bring private action
against the colleges and universities
again thank you so much for this
opportunity to talk about transparency
and cost and I'm happy to try to answer
any questions and also at the bottom
you'll notice the source which is
actually is also coming for the Federal
Register which really outlines a lot in
a lot more detail what they have planned
on the horizon Thank you very thank you
uh yes represent
leus I just want to make sure I
understand that the federal program is
going to be based on the actual course
of study major whatever so that they can
compare
um one course of study to another course
of study to make a good decision that
way is that correct that is correct I
believe it is going to be um organized
on what they call a sip code CIP um
which groups programs that are very
similar together thank you you're very
welcome yes represent
Ford thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question with this sort of a
provision also
include inducements by colleges and
universities to by lower tuition for
example uh to participate in certain
programs so that if you were going to
enroll in this program you would get a
lower tuition or in another program
you'd have to P the regular tuition
something to that effect I think you
know it's still um in its infancy um I
think the goal was really to get at that
openness and transparency to put the
information out there and that it really
would be the goal would really just be
to serve uh families and students
regarding exact costs as they as they
stand thank you
further
questions when you're publishing
information relating to let's say
tuition costs yes at a school and we
know that the tuition cost you read for
example like for UNH may be here but the
actual cost may be down here as a result
of grant program Grant programming which
is offered to students which one is
published so that so that we can get an
actual you know for if you're in this
income bracket your tuition may be
significantly reduced I would imagine
because it is based on a a website that
they would have to be created in a way
that would sort of fit the most number
of people in order to have it be useful
so if you're talking about an individual
student I think that would be very in
their circumstances their income and you
know all the things that you're alluding
to I think it would be kind of hard to
be able to print that out is on a
website so I would guess it would be
probably the average tuition I really
don't know it may be um printed uh
within the context of the of the
document we could check that out and see
uh Kathy prenter do you have any
comments on this particular topic is
you've been the treasurer of the state
and now you're
Chancellor not oh
well my name is centure I serve as the
chief administrative officer of
University system two quick
comments there's no fiscal note because
the university system and Community
College system were not provided the
bill to to um write a fiscal note and
number two the college scorecard does
provide net average tuition so it would
be net of financial aid but it's it's a
it's a big average and that um
information is generated from iPads m Mr
Cronin referred to earlier the I'm not
going to remember
the all the words in the acronym but
it's a database of um information that
is gathered from colleges across the
country by the federal government in
tuition financial
aid room board books fees all of that
and so it boils it down after financial
aid to an average cost of attendance for
countries uh schools Ross
country thank you very much are there
any further questions for thank
you are there any others who would like
to speak on this
bill not seeing we'll close close the
bill the
hearing 1436 done uh the next bill which
we have is HB
1690 relative to hiring promotion
graduation or admission in higher
education do we have a sponsor
here oh yeah we're got ahead of
ourselves
wow and you're going to be headed out
time to switch
Yeah okay
Margaret yeah
switch thank you very much you stayed
with it you stayed with
[Music]
it
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh Mike
beler that was
strange um yeah I'm not an author of
this however I do have some
understanding of the the policy position
that it's looking to take though the
technical details I might not be
particularly well versed in um so this
is core a an anti-discrimination Bill
and much like the last bill I introduced
it jumps significantly off of us of this
recent Supreme Court ruling that came
down um against Harvard University's
admission uh position now we saw in the
aftermath of that Supreme Court ruling
which prohibited using um different
metrics based on different mutable
characteristics to give preferential
treatment to any uh group of persons
that though um colleges began moving
away from the explicit and obvious um
discrimination that was being used as
the Supreme Court
highlighted we saw some colleges come
out um and openly say that what they
would essentially do is since they could
no longer utilize test scores and break
out things like that as a way to
discriminate what they would do is they
would simply solicit information in
means and some of those other means
include uh uh either self-reported or
the solicitation of what is so-called
diversity equity and inclusion
statements which are in this context
seeking to
assertain specific information about the
applicant um in terms of gender or
race whereby subjective measures can be
applied to a statement rather than
objective measures um such as test
scores and what that amounts to is is a
way of conducting the same sort of
discrimination which was ideologically
motivated um that was struck down by the
Supreme Court and burying it in a way
that makes it harder to harder to locate
um and in that same vein uh these the
requirement of these sorts of statements
which are essentially um ideological
statements of Faith are something that
should be prohibited in general um so be
Happ to answer any questions on on that
line again the technical aspects I
probably can't help with on this bill
but okay are
there any easy questions for represent
beler okay thank you very much thank
you like to ask that you both can come
up together if you want to Nadine Petty
and and Dy Morris uh nen you're from
UNH and and Dy you're from K uh keing
State
welcome right is it on yeah you're good
thank you everyone um so again my name
is Nan Petty I'm the chief diversity
officer from the University of New
Hampshire and I'm here this afternoon to
offer testimony in opposition to HB 1690
there are three main reasons for this
opposition and I would respectfully
request that this group also hold
opposition to that first HB 1690 is
redundant which makes it fully
unnecessary the usnh already adheres to
both state and federal anti-is
discrimination laws and has been in
compliance with these laws since
2012 in all aspects of hiring promotion
graduation and admission practices as it
specifically relates to hiring and the
use of diversity statements within
application materials um at UNH
specifically there are checks and
balances in place during various stages
of hiring to ensure that candidates meet
stated qualifications of job
descriptions something to note is that
information about the race ethnicity
gender disability status and other
protected identities of individual
applicants is withheld during search
committee deliberation processes to
ensure a fair and unbiased or as fair
and as unbiased to search outcome as
possible and I do want to correct
something that was um stated during the
introduction of the bill diversity
statements do not ask any applicant for
their race for their gender for any kind
of protected class
information applicants and the hiring
process are not required to include
information about their protected
identities in in diversity statements
the statements instead are used to
assess the ways that applicants are
prepared to engage in respectful and
productive interactions with students
and with colleagues regardless of
identities second HB 1690 is unclear and
it leaves room for interpretation and
misunderstanding as it relates to What A
diversity statement is and how such
statements are utilized within
usnh it is also unclear if the proposed
prohibition is addressing both written
statements and or verbal statements and
to what extent questions about diversity
and inclusion and usn's commitment to
these values or statements about
personal commitments to De are sometimes
initiated by applicants without
solicitation so it is also unclear if
the bill is proposing law to censor
incre queries or statements an applicant
might make of their own
valtion thirdly the proposal for private
citizens to bring legal action against
any New Hampshire institution who might
utilize diversity statements is
troubling giv the vagueness of the bill
itself there is a lack of understanding
of how diversity statements are used and
the Bill's lack of clarity will
inevitably subject usnh to expensive and
regular frivolous litigation that could
affect educational access for thousands
of students attending public
institutions across the
state I'd like to turn it over to
Dy uh good afternoon um as mentioned
before my name is dy moris and I'm the
associate vice president uh for
institutional equity and diversity at
keing State I've had the honor to serve
so many young adults uh since 2008 in
this position um so I've had
conversations with hundreds if not
thousands of young people in the state
of New Hampshire about uh this issue uh
I too would like to support my colleague
in opposing uh this particular bill and
the main reason is academic Excellence
uh these types of statements uh allow
for us to draw in more people to have
broader perspectives so the statements
that we are would ask of an applicant is
around perspective around how would they
provide an education that touches the
majority of students if not all students
so it's making them think in in an
intentional way about how do you best
provide a service for students and all
of my years of working with students as
I say I've been in this position since
20 2008 but I've been in higher ed uh
much longer than that I started when I
was 12 but this whole idea of of looking
at and hearing stories around young
people talking about what was so helpful
to challenge their own perspective the
way that they thought about things and
this is what these diversity statements
to get an idea of how people are
thinking about this who will be mentors
and will be supporters of young people
as they develop into the citizens that
we need not only in the state of New
Hampshire but in the United States and I
think by creating more and more
roadblocks to people being able to have
those discussions it doesn't allow for
us to give the best possible opportunity
to the young people in this state to be
very competitive outside of this state
and also to help this state grow and
mature as we know it can do so part of
the reason that these statements are
important part of the reason we have
statements of commitment for diversity
is because it's not just for a small
group of people it's for all students
and if we we could interview students uh
and find out they will definitely tell
you that they were challenged and in
that challenge they were able to create
more innovative solutions uh than they
would have with just having a singular
way of thinking about something and we
all know that there are some complex
issues we're dealing with and it'll take
multiple perspectives in order to um be
able to successfully navigate uh the
troubles that we have so for that reason
I would would ask for you to oppose uh a
statement that has not been used to
narrow the pool of people as a matter of
fact it's it's used to broaden it's used
to create an opportunity to have a rich
conversation within classrooms and to
allow for people on campus to feel like
they belong and they can be active and
engaged citizens of the United States of
America so I really do because of
academic excellence and all the other
things that we hope to have a strong
community and connection between
individuals from diverse backgrounds
that you oppose this thank you are there
any questions from the committee
representative cordelli thank you thank
you both for being here um I Heard a
little bit about what was not on the
diversity
statements um and a little bit about
what um you hope to accomplish with the
diversity statement could you tell us a
little bit about what is on the
diversity statement and and it's I think
it's quite important as this bill is
calling for um elimination of funding
for you if you have diversity statements
yeah so I'll go ahead and answer that
one so there is not a
specific statement in a diversity
statement so the search committees have
the right because we use them for not
even for all searches for some searches
for some positions we use them um
specifically to talk to what is going to
be be expected for the actual role that
we're we're hiring for so some examples
of some diversity prompts that have been
used in the past for example might be a
question that says tell us about how you
have um Incorporated inclusivity in your
field
research okay and that's one example or
tell us how you have considered
disability in your teaching
pedagogy that's another example those
are examples of diversity statements
that have been used at the University of
New
Hampshire thank you represent
mil thank you for being here and thank
you for taking my question what has the
impact of the Supreme Court decision had
on your work and how has it differ
differed as a result of that decision
thank are you referring to the
affirmative action yes yeah so it it
hasn't impacted us at all because we've
been following that rule for quite some
time so nothing changed I mean
essentially what we did is we went back
just to make sure that we were
continuing to follow those policies we
just sort of did a double check on our
practices and on our policies um just to
sh up anything that might have been a
loose end but like I said we've been
following anti-discrimination laws um
for quite some time and so there was no
impact to us
yeah further questions from the
committee I got one regarding Kean yes
um you have the C Co Center over there
which is an excellent Center dealing
with the Holocaust yes and your program
deals with diversity and acceptance of
differing positions and
thinking um how how is that occurring
over Keen right now are people all
accepting people that may be Jewish or
maybe Muslim or maybe Presbyterian and
without right um this other stuff that's
going on in our country yeah as with
with all human behavior it's complicated
and so what we are providing
are opportunities for people to have
those conversations and not just a
surface level conversation but the type
of conversation that attends to the
nuances and the complexities involved in
all of this and so in our efforts to do
that uh we make it very clear around
expectations of interacting with one
another uh we don't silence anyone in
that in that I idea of having those
conversations and it is being led by the
coin Center and a couple other uh
organizations on campus we've had
several conversations and I felt like
they were very productive conversations
on campus over the past few uh months
thank you further questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
today thank
you Shannon
Reed these were his
introduced CES good afternoon I'm
Shannon Reed representing the community
college system of New
Hampshire um we respectfully oppose this
bill and I would I would Echo some of
what you've heard before the community
college system is subject to existing
state and federal
anti-discrimination laws and we take
adherence to these principles and these
laws very seriously U however there's
there's significant uncertainty in some
of the language of house 1690 and the
severe penalties for non-compliance are
of great concern um I go to specifics
and I'll give a few examples in the bill
so for example in the hiring environment
a candidate for a position might wish to
highlight something in their background
that demonstrates experience supporting
diversity and Equity initiatives would
receiving such a statement place the
institution at risk for non-compliance
with this bill since the word that's
used is permitting um an institution
can't permit diversity equity and
inclusion statements what exactly does
that mean in the um in the hiring
environment it's also unclear how
broadly this language would be construed
Beyond um hiring for example within
institutional strategic plans that
address a commitment to equity to
diversity Andor to inclusion with
respect to the populations that we
strive to
serve um further language on page page
one line 26 talks about nothing in this
section shall be interpreted as
prohibiting Bonafide qualifications
based Bas on sex which are reasonably
necessary to the normal operation of
public employment Etc we're not sure
what that language is is intended to
allow and we'd appreciate if the sponsor
might be able to provide some
clarification of that um the language
that authorizes any citizen to bring
suit against to college is is either
ambiguous or very Broad and could be
interpreted to allow a wide spectrum of
people to bring a lawsuit potential
Awards could include court cost and
attorneys fees which could create an
incentive for new Suites that could
become draining of both institutional
time and legal
resources um let's see for the lawyers
in the room the evidentiary standard in
the bill is atypical for civil actions
and puts the college at a legal
disadvantage once a plan if makes a
prasy case against the college the
burden shifts to the college prove to
prove it has not violated a statute and
the college must do so via an
evidentiary standard of clear and
convincing evidence civil cases usually
have a preponderance of the evidence
standard so the standard in this chapter
is more difficult to meet than in a
typical civil case also the college is
being asked to prove a negative that it
did not violate the statute we also have
major concerns with the language that
sets out the institution's liability and
financial exposure while we would
attempt in good faith to comply with the
state law duly enacted if the
institutions found to be in violation of
this
chapter and the full penalties contained
therein and forced we would be required
to Forfeit the entire amount of State
funding we would otherwise receive in a
given year rendering the organization
unable to operate and unable to meet its
commitment to
students I would point out also that the
community colleges are open access
institutions meaning um we don't make
the kinds of admissions decisions that
might um you know where certain
demographic information might come into
play as is the case potentially with
other institutions and when we talk
about diversity equity and inclusion at
ccsnh we talk about being places where
anyone can Thrive as a student as an
employer as as an employee I mean um our
Chancellor likes to say that New
Hampshire given its labor force
challenges and um wanting to be to
retain a high quality of life in this
state and high levels of Civic
engagement we cannot afford to leave
Talent on the bench which means we need
to create opportunities for all New
Hampshire residents um which means
paying attention to what we can do to be
those places where anyone can Thrive um
so I'll I'll stop there because I don't
want to be too repetitive of what's been
said I'm happy to take any any questions
but we would ask you to consider iing
this Bill thank you any questions of the
community college
system so what would happen to the
community college system if you made a
mistake here and you would lose all your
revenue from the
state that's my reading of the bill and
at this point we're about 50% funded
Yeah by state appropriation
yeah big
dollars
okay any further questions from the
committee thank you very
much are there any other folks want to
talk uh on this particular bill in the
audience not seeing any we will close
this hearing on 1690 and enter the last
one for the day 3:00 to start so pardon
me it's a 3 o' to start so plus we
on I don't know if there's anyone here
to test can't we declare our El in a
different time zone yeah it's 5:00
somewhere do we have it's 5:00 somewhere
yes do we have cards for this bill no no
which one is this is uh
1534 1534 right
um okay whose bill is
this obviously people are not looking at
the
calendar and are we still getting uh
emails for notice of
build yeah we should be this went
out well we'll get it done
quickly just open it up and close
it it used to be if a person didn't show
up
for today it's HB 1534 rela to to
establishing a program to earn tuition
credits for State of New Hampshire
higher education institutions through
community service and I'd like to
welcome the sponsor of the bill
representative Schultz and with
representative Schultz is Morgan
Casey welcome thank you Mr chair it's
the first time I've appeared before your
committee so it's an honor to finally be
here um with so many great Educators and
former school officials Etc that is
really cool um I am a rep for conquered
in four three Wards including Ward four
where we're sitting right now and it is
my honor to serve um and I am excited to
be the sponsor of this bill because of a
constituent of mine Morgan Casey who is
a student at Bishop Brady and this is
really she wrote the Bill and I'm here
to be of service to this bill and I
think actually she's got a better speech
than I could have written so if it's
okay with you Mr chair I would like to
defer to her that's
fine thank you rep awesome thank you rep
Schultz and Mr chair my name is Morgan
Casey and like rep schs mentioned I am a
senior at Bishop Brady High School this
is my first time testifying for piece of
legislation and it is a pleasure to be
here to introduce to you my triple win
policy this idea developed out of a
homework project and some encouragement
from students I met at the US Senate
youth program in March I'm grateful to
representative Leno and representative
Schultz for their energy and
encouragement they have been great
mentors the national media has brought
significant attention to the prevailing
student loan crisis which has generated
Divergent viewpoints regarding potential
remedies as of 2023 and overwhelmingly
93% of students bear some form of
student loan debt collectively amounting
to 1.6
trillion this predicament pervades every
corner of our nation and including our
own State of New
Hampshire President Biden employed an
executive order providing $1 to $20,000
in attempt to alleviate this issue but
it was ruled
unconstitutional Democrats and
Republicans also differ in their views
on this issue to find a middle ground
and offer a solution that appeases both
political parties I wanted to introduce
specific legislation pertaining to the
state of New
Hampshire this proposal aims to
Institute a unique option for tuition
credit to alleviate future student loan
debt within our state this bill proposes
that the state of New Hampshire credits
$2,500 a year if a student volunteers a
100 hours in one calendar year at state
approved sites such as nursing homes
food banks or homeless
shelters this opportunity would be
available to all high school and college
students attending a public institution
in New Hampshire or from New Hampshire
this offer would be renewable for up to
8 years totaling a possibility of
$20,000 in tuition
credit I think that this bill would
benefit the students the community and
the state I appreciate your time in
listening to this proposal and I'm
hopeful that New Hampshire could serve
as a pilot for this program and help be
a leader on the student debt crisis
thank you Mr chair I would like to add
um I should have also mentioned I also
attended Catholic school where I grew up
and service is a huge component of a
Catholic Education which I'm proud to
have had and to be able to think of this
as sort of instead of taking out student
loans if you need to this would give
students who've already been
contributing to the community to pay for
college in a way that would be I think
fair and representative of the service
that a lot of young people such as Miss
Casey um want to do for the state New
Hampshire so it really is of great
benefit and I'm honored to be the
sponsor can I and if we have any
questions we're willing to take them
okay thank you are there any questions
from the committee representative
cascaden thank you Mr chair and thank
you to both of you for presenting this
um my question is you have in line 16 um
that it would be an an approved
volunteer
site who who is doing the approving and
who's going to validate the number of
hours so I take that if you want okay
sure um we would be um open to your
feedback on this but essentially the
creation of the program would lay out
the administration of it so um the
administrators of the program so this
would be um if you want you already were
talking about approved sites so um I was
also thinking that this could be part of
a Department of Education role um in a
similar way that for mandated community
service um those have been approved
activities or organizations we could
follow a similar sort of system in which
the department of Ed would create state
approved volunteer sites and then follow
a kind of record system like the um
prison or mandatory community service
uses so that's kind of managed at a
state level and then and if
organizations not initially um approved
by the department of Ed maybe in the
future they could apply to be a state
approved volunteer site if they were a
commun if they were an organization in
need followup followup chch um is there
any reason why it wouldn't go through
your local school district as the
approving um we're open to that idea it
just makes it local local control
sure thank you representative penell and
then representative Damon thank you Mr
chair and thank you very much for coming
in proposing this legislation and for
taking my question can you tell me how
much
um a high school student would make if
they were employed sure so I um actually
worked at a sandwich shop downtown um
the in the past summer and I I was
making about $155 or $16 an hour um my
friends who are currently employed make
between 12 and I would say $16 an hour
working and so part some of the um ways
that we came up with the
$2,500 for 100 hours of service is that
we want to make the offer appealing if
students are able to work and make more
and earn more money to possibly pay for
tuition than this program was offer it
would kind of lose that appeal so we
wanted to make sure that the students
time was being valued and that they were
being compensated fairly for that
volunteer time they were putting into
these
organizations thank you very much
excellent answer represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and proposing this
really I think impressive approach I'm
wondering if you would be comfortable
with an amendment that specifies that
the um organization that the student is
volunteering in is a 501c3
nonprofit I'm sure we would be but I I
wouldn't want to exempt potential
service to government entities were
appropriate so as long as uh because
that's technically not a nonprofit um I
think that was our goal was to look at
where are there needs and um government
type assistance um when I did my junior
service in high school I said can I
volunteer from my congressman you know
so things like that should also be
available if someone wanted to uh read
to or work on literacy at the prison if
allowed you know programs like that
shouldn't um be off the table do you
want to clarify I'm not personally
familiar with what that organiz or what
that title is would you mind clarifying
for me please it's a federal filing that
many nonprofits do that basically
credentials that they are a nonprofit
organization is that an output
definition anybody else want to step
in we're it's it's a taxation issue okay
yeah it's yeah gives Credence to being a
nonprofit
okay further further questions from the
committee represent
beler thank you Mr chair thank you for
bringing this bill in for answering
these questions
um my question is um so if we're
volunteering and we're being compensated
at a rate of up to $25 an hour for that
doer work and that is taxpayer money
that's being utilized that is in in
essence being earned through this labor
that's being done um I'm curious on line
21 why it would specifically restrict it
from being used in private colleges it
would only be available for public
institutions well I think that is an
interesting point that we could consider
um you made the point about taxpayer
dollars I will say there are already
student loan forgiveness programs
available to high-paying workers in
various biotech jobs and those don't
have any parameters at all um as far I
could be wrong correct me if I'm wrong
someone here probably does know that but
I'm pretty sure they don't have any
parameters for Inc come uh or first you
know any other sort of issue around that
um as long as they're here in New
Hampshire jobs um th that forgiveness is
paid for by the taxpayer as well so this
would I will defer the other part of the
question about why not private colleges
to uh Miss
Casey um in a
simp we initially said Public Schools
um public school students and public
universities just because I was thinking
that we want
um for example I I'm going to a private
Catholic school right now and service is
something that's a mandatory part of my
it's one of the pillars of the school
service and education and so we wanted
to really make that opportunity
available to public school students and
typically um the public
universities have um lower tuition costs
than some of these private institutions
and so making that more affordable um
for example I think the UNH the average
UNH in state tuition is about
$30,000 and this um proposal could
significantly cut into that where some
of the private um institutions with $60
plus thousand tuition it might not Mak
as much of an impact but I'm not we're
not opposed to including private
universities
also yes representative Woodcock thank
you Mr
chair M Casey thank you so much for
bringing this I appreciate that and
you're your work um my my question
follows up a little bit on repres
belches so is your am I understanding
this right there actually wouldn't be a
CRA a cash transaction if if the way you
have it apparently structured
the state institution would see say a
credit or a reduction in your tuition
bill that you get and there just be a
credit so the the state school wouldn't
get 2
$2500 um period right there' be a
reduction um that's where it come from
this the school would reduce that is
that your intent that's correct this um
proposal the credit so to speak would
have no cash value it would just be it
would lower that tuition bill okay okay
may fall up one more sure thank you
um if I uh started in school a say UNH
this community college in I started at
UNH and I do my first year and I uh
decide to trans drop out or transfer to
uh keing
State uh can I get back in the program
and your understanding or is it just
like you was one school I'm thinking
about how they're going to follow this
around or you're not sure yet I think it
would make sense to um allow it to be
available to any of our fine public
institutions in New Hampshire so I can't
think of a reason why I wouldn't
continue I mean you we could think of
this and could name it a scholarship
program maybe that is more at in the
concept that we're trying to reach with
this bill um and it didn't occur to me
till this moment the college scholarship
um that probably actually is more
accurate um you know a public service
scholarship to go to our public
institutions I think makes sense but to
um also as a way to keep students here
but to get to your question um
absolutely it should be portable okay
that my question thank you Mr chair
you're welcome further question
represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much Miss Casey and
representative Schultz for uh for
bringing this in this afternoon um
I was wondering if um if you're aware
that if a high school student
began uh volunteering under this program
at 100 hours a year beginning their
freshman year repeat doing it again
sophomore year junior year and Senior
year that uh that they would amass
enough tuition credit to essentially
have um tuition and fees fully paid for
um enrollment at a at a two-year
Community College and uh earn a valuable
uh uh uh two-year degree following
that
sure yes I think so so and then and a
followup Mr chair yes and and given the
um given the the um uh really the
workforce issues that we're we're facing
here in New Hampshire I know that's
compounded by a lot of other issues too
like housing and and transportation and
things like that but U but do you see
that as a um as a as a
positive um because it's not an
insignificant investment by the state
$25 million a year is what uh is what's
estimated in the fiscal note um but
given that we're already spending close
to $45 million a year on community
community college that this would be a
good uh a good investment for the state
absolutely thank you repino for your
question and yes I think I definitely
see that as a positive benefit one of
the the things with this proposal is to
not only help students kind of reduce
that barrier to entry and be able to get
that college education but also when
they're doing this volunteer service and
are in these communities maybe forming
relationships to like you said possibly
create Career Connections and when we're
making um College more accessible and
affordable for New Hampshire students
they're likely to stay in state for that
school and it's helping our state gain
those young professionals that can
contribute to the workforce that can
help um hopefully like um prevent some
of that Workforce shortage and
ultimately generate economic output for
our
state thank you are there are there any
further
questions so for example in my my
district Woodsville High School requires
community service for
graduation um and and they get the
credit for that that um would the
students then are doing it within the
school environment they go out and clean
part of the Appalachian Trail they do
all kinds of things for community
service because that's where we live up
in the mountains um would they receive
the credit plus this $2,500 you're
talking about if they're taking it
through their course at school which is
community
service so can I just clarify when
you're speaking about credit are they
receiving academic credit for those
hours they're meeting all the academic
credits required by the department see
we can to graduate in the state you have
to have 20 credits some schools maybe I
don't know where Bishop Brady is so
probably more than that 26 credits or so
some are asking for more which are
electives and this is an elective but
sort of like a required elective you
don't graduate unless you do community
service um so if that were to occur
would that be Al would that individual
student all of them all the kids that
are graduating it's small school only
240,000 240 kids in high school very
small it's another door you're opening
up uh I'm open to the committee's
feedback on this but I think that that
would that would be reasonable and be
allowed in this proposal now I have one
other question for you and this is
getting down into the
finances we have a program called the
education tax credit M and that's done
working with business other words they
put this money in the kitty and you know
so much of it you know goes to state so
much goes to the individual that's going
to you know for education purposes for
tuition where is the revenue coming for
this $25 million it's tax credit yes but
where's the revenue come
from sure um I would say it would
probably be the same source of where uh
student loan forgiveness is given to
those um industries that receive the
student loan forgiveness credit here
that is a state program and I assume
that's the general funds but I'm not
sure of the answer of that um looks like
repun there're different sources like
UNH offers Grant or grants as well but
that's something they do internally
within
UNH so the tuition you see is not
necessarily Stu the tuition that the
students pay it's usually a lot less we
get that this is a very important
question on any Bill yes um we are
flexible and um would expect that this
would also uh be considered an economic
development possibility even though
they're
nonprofits because of the needs the
Urgent needs even at our County nursing
homes Etc um this would be an added um
value because of that so I think that
investment pays for itself in a way I
also get that that is easy to say and
we're flexible in how to come to that
and I do have one last follow up on all
this we have a number of students in
this state that go to New London to
school for college kobby Sawyer and
that's because they want to get into the
nursing program at Dartmouth Hitchcock
but it's a private
school um and and costly more so than
unh um so we talked a little bit about
the private colleges being eligible if
they they go to a private college in New
Hampshire we our goal is to keep these
kids in New Hampshire and employed after
they in New Hampshire after they
graduate from college this would be
another way of of
of accomplishing that end if we involv
the private schools colleges that are in
our state but then see that's then
funding it is going to be a little bit
different than than what you've
initially talked about here because they
they're not State
schools represent luno figure out right
no no thank you very much Mr chair and
um and could it could
it could it possibly also be done
through through Partnerships with
private um institutions like Colby
Sawyer uh in New London where they
recognize the value of um of students uh
commed to the state doing community
service and potentially um a school like
kobby Sawyer could also issue tuition
credits the same way uh our state
universities or community colleges could
do would that be a possibility I think
yes that that could be a possibility in
this proposal great thank
you yes represent
Damon I'm wondering if there was any
consideration of uh evaluating a
student's Financial need Or would simply
all public high school students
qualify I mean whatever you want
to however you want to say we we are
flexible on this um initially it was not
need-based it was kind of dependent on
the amount of hours of service performed
it was available to all students kind of
regardless of that um financial
situation but we we are flexible on that
option again I think that goes to the
point that current student loan
forgiveness programs that are
state-based I don't believe have any
sort of income contingency um I do see a
benefit to that but we're talking really
about the um value of service and that
can come from someone with a wealthy
background or someone not with a wealthy
background that value stands on its own
probably but we're
flexible I definitely appreciate the
value of service and applaud that
premise and I'm also trying to make the
fiscal note look more
appealing nice maybe I'll just do it
from a policy perspective and then have
Ways and Means figure this one
out
financially any any fur further
discussion from the committee on this
bill do we have any other folks that
wanted to testify on this represent
Ford
is that thank you
um if you move from service by
definition to experience-based
education then you have a better
position for asking for AP credit or
something like that which automatically
guarantees the
transferability because it's
Incorporated in a course and so you
created a course of experience
that's a good point and that's the
nature and that moves it along as a
course so when you transfer to another
College the question is do they exper
accept credit for experience-based
education and that's increasingly common
these days could address that too thank
thank you for that suggestion I think
maybe incorporating that as a credit
would help it be more flexible to
transition between different schools
like you were mentioning so thank you
for that suggestion I'll just say though
I don't know how that program works now
but I know in the past not every school
would offer the same courses and so I
think that's dependent on the
availability of that AP course I assume
that's still the case um my school only
offered it for sociology and psychology
for whatever reason so I think it would
have to that would only be helpful if
your school offers that college credit
AP course but maybe you know more about
one other thing I'd like to mention is
that as currently written this proposal
is available for college students to
continue that work in service and
receive tuition credit so thinking about
maybe that's an option for high school
students performing service but um also
would that kind of carryover once
they're in college and taking college
classes how to incorporate that as a
class and I think that's going to depend
largely on the college the college is
looking for the student they'll admit
it further questions from the committee
yes wood car represent
Hall how to do it thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I would
think um well I'm looking at this 20%
number and I'm going to follow up on
representative lad when he said high
schools um do indeed for for graduation
they need to do community service uh so
would you
believe I have to make it a question so
would you believe that I I guess I'm
thinking think that we need to know you
need to know how many
schools make that a requirement for
graduation that they need to do so many
hours of community service because you
could have a lot of schools at
100% it wouldn't be 100% because they
don't all go on to school but um it
could be a lot more than this 20% number
so just I would suggest getting that
number that is a great thing to seek an
answer for thank you for raising that
question thank
you
represent Woodcock thank you and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak
again after the representative Hall um I
know it's the cause that work session as
you're here uh Morgan you won't be here
at the other time but as I was listening
to the dialogue I was thinking when
represent L talked about would they get
volunteer get credit for volunteering
that obviously that wouldn't be the same
if was it was a high school requirement
they really wouldn't be volunteering to
do the do the class but um beyond that I
was thinking reverse two two parts of
your bill is how to get and the
represent brought the big issue of the
dollar which is accurate is a big issue
one this one 25 million um if you did if
you thought about two things a if you
made it only uh for high school
youngsters going into college um if that
was your intent if you if that's small
of the bill and secondly if you're going
to use do the reverse and had just
College age youngsters participating
then perhaps it could be something that
that would be reduced if they worked in
New Hampshire after graduation so that
would come off of there so you're
cutting Revenue but you're also working
to keep people inh just thoughts as
you're thinking about um how on this
construct for this bill how could
possibly pass just thoughts thank you
represent life
leeway represent cordelli thank you
thank you very much uh for bringing this
forward and both being here um I would
just point out the um when you're
looking at the 20% um of students taking
advantage of this and the $25 million
per student
um that was based on just the uh high
school students but college students are
also eligible for this right now so the
cost could be considerably higher than
the $25 million price tag in the fiscal
note so you might want to consider um
the eligible student population that
you're dealing with
right that's good
point any further questions or
brainstorming on this bill well
that's thank thank you very much and
thank you Mr chair and to the committee
and um it's been an honor to work with
Miss Casey and I think maybe she's
better at this than me and I'm honored
to have brought this uh forward with her
thank you thank you so um thank you Mr
chair and thank you for the committee
the committee letting us present this
proposal today um I also just want to
say once again thank you to
representative SCH and representative
Leno for your guidance um and support in
this Pursuit so thank you one of the
things just to wrap it up when we moved
forward with the Dual and concurrent
enrollment program when we went forward
of some of those programs which assist
high school students to get credits
prior to graduating from high school we
slid into the program rather than going
full boore we only had grades 11 and 12
we've since gone down to grades 10 11
and 12 and we once had only stem courses
now we're allowing to be any course and
so once you get get get it going get the
roots in the ground then you can expand
and that's how we've done many program
so it's something you might you know
look at is it better to just go get 80%
or 50% now and then expand it in a year
or two once it really gets rolling
something to consider excellent thank
thank you thank you for that feedback
yeah all righty well with that we don't
have any more testimony on that bill so
we'll conclude that hearing and we'll
see everybody tomorrow morning at what
time 9 is it
9: who schedule
that electric pending yeah no that I've
heard that we will be meeting those are
the finance bills but that's that's fine
you know we all don't to be here
um